and we are here for more junior speed chess
championship coverage i'm grand master
robert hess alongside me is the inimitable
grandmaster simon williams simon it's been a
long time since we we've commented together
but i'm certainly looking forward to today
yeah certainly robert i mean we were just
trying to work out when the last time we
commentated together was and we we we couldn't
we couldn't figure it out but um it's going
to be a great day chess today this is uh a
semi-final i'm very much looking forward to
oh i am as well and honestly it's been so long
it could be before one of these partitions was
born because when we're dealing with the jscc and
in particular nihal sarin he is a young superstar
from india hike martirosian is an absolute beast
in the online servers but he's 20 years old you
know he's yeah he's too old for this at this
point and neil saaren is just a young teenager
a superstar uh both the present and the future of
the world of jazz yeah certainly i mean this this
match is going to be a fantastic match um i've met
nihal a couple of times i sort of shared a place
with him even a couple years ago in iceland very
very nice kid i don't know hike so much but their
chess talent is going from strength to strength
and to call this match i i mean it's going to be
very interesting as we'll see soon but we're in
for a great afternoon here morning there of chess
so it's going to be fantastic i feel we certainly
are and it is as close to a toss-up you can not
favored available is as well in the three plus
one but then the bullet favors nihal sarin
and simon i often feel like in these matches if
you keep it close and when you get to the bullet
the side that's better at bullet can pull through
at the end yeah certainly i mean these matches um
they they often sort of someone gets a bit of a
role going which can happen and they can get a
little bit of the lead but then the other person
gets a role going a lot of it i think is just
that sort of energy behind the moves but you're
right if it goes to a close situation going into
the bullet section um anything can happen because
you get a lot of games going on it's quite random
i've seen knee how and hike both play bullet
obviously they're both amazing but niihau is
so tricky he's such a tricky little flagger i've
seen him flag so many people before obviously it's
a bit harder to flag at this time limit because
it's one second extra move but it's uh it's going
to be extremely extremely close the match it
certainly will and hike was so impressive in
his win over parham maxoudlu in the quarterfinals
and parham obviously no slouch both to the broader
world of chess and the online chess community in
particular that's a former world junior champion
somebody who's always rated towards the top of the
leaderboard so hike much rosen proves that he can
you know fight with the best them here and he is
the slight favorite today i was a bit surprised
by that because nihal is the top seed but that's
just how well ike martirosian has played thus far
yes i am i mean again it could go either way
i mean if i was going to pick someone it's
like it really is so hard uh to say i think
it's who's going to be best on the day um
i i can't really pick one person to win it i was
very impressed i wanted to say the way hike played
in his last match that was really clever he kept
fighting even in positions where he was much
behind really struggling he was so resourceful
and you have to have that resourcefulness but
knee how has that same level of resourcefulness
which is shown time and time again um if i'm
looking at results at title tuesday events i know
they got the stats there but i'm just doing this
without any stats given to me but i know that hike
is always always up there at the top neil knee how
has been but hike has been consistently there i
don't know it's going to be interesting be good
to see what people think in the chat um of who's
going to win and yeah what do you think robert
do you are you gonna put your neck on the line
here oh my gosh it's so tough because nihal was
struggling out of the gate and we actually have
left off right now but he was struggling out of
the gates against anton smirnov and he pulled
through in the end because of the bullet so he
kept it close enough went to the bullet and
then took that match but haike martyrossen
is a super tough player as you see just by their
ratings they're about even 30 31 for hike 30 18
for nihal sorry and that can change with every
single game and it will and i guess simon now
the chess is here i'm not gonna put my neck on the
line because i just did a really roundabout way of
talking about other things uh i'm gonna all right
i'll go nihal sirens slight favorite that's where
i'm going with this okay i'm gonna have to go the
other way robert just to be different so i'm gonna
i'm gonna go hike slight favorite but i do know
me how better so i you know he was a very nice you
know guy to analyze with so i kind of like to see
me how win i know we're not supposed to be biased
got nothing against hike it's just that when you
know someone slightly better you kind of you're
kind of rooting for them but starting off with
quite a sort of solidish um semi-slave here robert
yeah you know not uh not the most exciting in
the early stages but there's a lot of potential
in such a position because this bishop on c8 for
black you to figure out am i playing b6 and then
bring this bishop out to say b7 or a6 and is black
playing for c5 that's sort of the main question i
have and then from white's perspective over here
oh what is your actual plan here are you going
to push e4 at some moment are you just going to
move your bishop out in castle i'm sorry what do
you think is going to happen in this one i'm what
i i think knee how's starting you know nice nice
solid structure here because the other option
which i think maybe even gary kasparov played a
couple of times was castling queen side for white
that would have let you that would have led to
a very exciting sort of battle in both areas but
i think he's just deciding maybe after last match
right let's just get into the game and you can
see this now by the trade on d5 he's simplifying
the position not really going for a big advantage
but just trying to get some small nibble from the
position here um but black is very solid here as
well and he plays a6 i was about to mention that
the one major difference is that there's a knight
on c3 compared to a knight on d7 the knight on d7
a superfluous knight because there's a knight in
f6 stopping its progress to march forward and the
pawn on d4 pawn three squares from away from a
knight always dominates that knight your knight
can't get forward so that is a slightly better
piece placement for white but nothing all that
major especially after a6 saying hey your knight's
not getting to b5 and you're not getting to the c7
square yes i mean this kind of exchange has been
played before but black has certainly got the
right idea here transferring that knight towards
the queen side just getting rid of the worst place
piece and maybe even as a knight e4 later on in
the game to try and use the bishop on b7 and get
a bit of activity a very solid start here white
on the other hand has the open c file where he
has potential to come into c7 at some point with a
queen and uh you know put push push over there but
it's it's looking fairly even they're sort of you
know like two boxes they're kind of not swinging
they're not swinging too fast at the moment
they're just eyeing up each other at this uh
at this stage of the game certainly and one now
major difference with the pawn b5 is if white
can get a knight to c5 because you've that's a
potential outpost you don't have a pawn that can
kick a knight from that square whereas if this
knight goes b6 knight c4 why can just play b3
and say hey shoot you you look good there for
the moment but you're not lasting very long
yes and black now going for exchanges
which is a typical way to try and
simplify the position more and i mean if anyone's
better here i'd say white is slightly better
because of the position of those light square
bishops as well uh white has a better sort of
diagonal even though it's not necessarily doing
too much maybe even white can try some i can't
see at the moment but i was thinking a4 at some
point but it's there's no problems of black here
at the moment how i mean the two moves i'd say
they have to watch out for are these knight jumps
maybe knight e4 95 that could change the sort of
dynamics of the position and you know you always
want to consider that if you're going to try and
push for a win especially in such a symmetrical
uh position as this yeah and another thing
i'll notice this rook and f8 would rather be an
a8 because then you could trade on c1 and bring
a second rook to the c file whereas white can
take on c8 and then replace the rook with his
work and he actually does just that so a slight
lead in terms of you know who's getting into
the action first but will that be consequential
i don't really see how you take advantage of
the fact that you're already on the c file
no and now now black is ready to play this
rook c8 move and exchange off that sort of one
advantage that white kind of had there the open
c file white making exchanges on g3 i mean the
only thing i can sort of see maybe white trying to
do is an a4 move later on to try and probe those
pawns but even that move seems a long way off um
so i don't know i mean maybe if rook c8 is played
can he exchange it go 95 that's something worth
considering but it's risky okay blacks black's
played it very solidly here maybe queen d6 at
some stage as well yeah just trading everything
off simon but i i do think that there's more life
left in the position than i would initially care
to admit because this bishop on d3 is so much
better than the bishop on b7 you mentioned this
94 idea in end games in particular i'll just take
your knight on e4 and play knight against a bishop
that doesn't attack anything so there is potential
for black to initiate a wrong trade yes and um
i suppose the other thing as you mentioned
robert is if white can ever get a knight into c5
this is a square later on that knight can maybe
travel you know to d2 b3 or something like this
you you'll pitch it on the board and you know
black will struggle to exchange that whilst
white can stop blacks knights coming in maybe that
b5 pawn is a little bit overextended it's it's not
much at all at the moment um but if i was white i
certainly want to play this position on um for as
long as i could just to see if i can get anything
out of it i'm with you and actually i might even
consider keeping the queens on the board queen d2
say wait a sec that c5 square that we keep talking
about maybe i can get there going knight to b3
next especially now yeah yeah king on d6 queen
d2 i mean come on i need to get to b4 with check
what's your king doing out here yeah queen d2
looks like a really strong move here because you
know he's played it he's played it i mean black's
banking on the queen exchange now but with the
queen coming to b4 and the knight coming to b3
this can actually be quite a serious advantage
brewing here with those that knight swinging in
to one of those great squares on a5 and c5 and the
black king probably wants to walk its way back now
you know put it back on g8 it's sort of done this
walk to walk to death there i mean okay it's not
going to get checkmated but it can always come
across annoying checks uh in this position here
which will gain white tactical opportunities for
sure and you know you want to look at base pawns
g7 f7 if the king goes to b8 and this queen does
get to b4 into squad e7 you have to watch out that
you won't just lose some of your pawns on the
king side as well as the fact that this knight
is coming to b3 okay and if you go knight
to b6 you're welcoming my knight into b3 or
this night into e5 where i attack f7 right away
simon this is starting to look really really good
for nihal definitely i mean now that knight has
the opportunity to come into e5 maybe here um
before black can go knight on f to d7 or something
and okay the check makes a lot of sense and now
the king okay well he's he's building up
the forces here yeah queen and knight this
is actually all of a sudden change massively
for black black should have played queen takes
c1 got rid of those queens before venturing the
king up to the board like this yeah i mean right
now there might even be bishop takes b5 check
because once i take back i check and hit your
knight on a4 but you have to calculate you don't
want to you know risk too much here as white by
sacking a piece but i get the feeling that this
just works bishop b5 check takes queen takes you
have to play bishop c6 in order to defend your
knight and then there's like 95 check and maybe
yeah and he's got time to think about such a move
as well because this timeline does give you that
that benefit here and something like this could
just be winning simple as that um with the black
king again you can see it just in this diabolical
situation here i mean can you hold on i mean king
d6 just doesn't look like it should hold on um i
think it's over because you have to bring the king
and i just take the bishop and yeah was your night
yeah yeah yeah so is he going to find it let's see
would he find bishop b5 because um if he does find
this move which he's thinking about he's got time
this is very clever of me how he's using his time
when he's spotted a tactic he wants to make sure
the tactic is working you can see he's calculating
it i really expect he's gonna find this bishop
takes b5 move this the this this this i mean all
right he's gonna find it isn't he robert he must
i mean he can be thinking about 95 check and then
the consequence of king ea queen d6 something like
that but yeah he's played it he's played it and
this could just be game over already actually a
very smooth game here from niha i mean that's very
positive because he's never been worse and he's
okay this big mistake of black moving the king
and that's assuming he's going to win this one is
is a nice way to start without ever being in
trouble at all yeah it's sort of funny simon
that this game was decided by the fact that
hike didn't trade queens and even if he had
traded queens we were talking about how white has
a slight pull because of the superior minor pieces
in particular this bishop on b7 is very bad behind
upon d5 and so now hike is down a couple of pawns
he's going to try to somehow survive this but it's
not looking very likely no maybe white can sort of
give a check and bring the queen back somewhere
sensible like to c3 worst case scenario d2
um there might be a better way of playing this of
course um black's best bet is certainly to throw
the queen in try to get the knight to e4 and to
complicate he's not risking anything now by by
playing such a plan but um i'm assuming that white
can cover all these squares um with careful play
must be a way i'm not maybe there's queen b5 check
bishop c6 and queen c5 so forcing the bishops
he goes he's going this way he's going for a
tactical finish queen before where like where's
the where is the finish that's always the annoying
thing at least i find silence i know i'm up two
pawns i should be winning yeah where is the actual
win yeah we saw this actually a lot in in the last
match with uh hike and parham was getting these
kind of positions but he wasn't actually finishing
him off and it's that finishing touch which is
so important and hike was so resilient even in
these losing positions i expect that knee how will
simply wings he's got his queen c1 move uh here
but um going for his best option and again this
this seems sensible to at least try keeping the
queens on the board to complicate the situation as
much as you possibly can very clever check there
that you pointed out robert putting that bishop on
c6 where it's now going to be a target to attack
yet actually this is another miss by nihal he
could have forced the queens off by instead of
playing his queen back to d2 look at the time
as well i mean this is this is a position where
okay of course you're winning but you know
suddenly there's a threat yeah suddenly you could
get mated if you're not careful yeah 94 you may
be a tricky mcqueen h1 check forcing a block on
the f1 square but i mean white has to push these
pawns at some point not so easy to accomplish
i mean white is doing well but the time situation
now it is going to complicate this matter a lot he
just if he gets the queens off he's laughing if he
gets the queens off he's laughing but he's got to
work away or just maybe push the pawns that's
queen f5 he wants to get his queen in this oh
just stopping that move yeah all these squares are
covered yeah somehow and if he's just pushing his
apartment like can you just keep going he wants
he wants the queen why not and push it again he's
done it yes oh nice fine hits the bishop and now
quimby five check and go into yeah get into the
position here still gonna be a little bit careful
because the black king's very safe here and all of
a sudden white's king's very open is this so
clear even no i i mean it's it's seems to be
i don't know i mean it just seems like there could
you have to watch out for perpetual say queen is
coming in right can you one does queen e3 oh oh i
don't know about this black's got at least a draw
right right queen d1 queen e2 the king's trying to
run to age three but it doesn't get too far yeah
and you can see nihal on the uh on the camera is
oh can can black even get the knight in and try
to win this why not like you know 83 and then you
want something like that i what is he's going oh
he took the pawn hanging what happened there that
wasn't a check no but i guess there's queen h one
was the threat this is getting confusing i mean
they're just moving so quickly and oh here comes
the knight okay so he's risking it he's he's
allowing white to queen and i think he might
be he might be very close to mating nihal with
knight f2 is that right yeah the wrong knight move
apparently i see the bar the bar swung where's the
draw oh queen takes g7 okay c4 what a move getting
the king the g3 square oh this is tense this is
tense stuff now whoa and somehow this is just
zeros i see the bar over there zeros of course
well it's still a bit of play here yeah i mean
it should it should of course be a draw but um
queen g7 um queen take pawn queen f4 why can't you
go queen is that working i don't know if that's
what i was trying to figure out really quickly
too much queen f6 this is also working king g3
and then king f4 after you take on b3 you get
me this has been messy rob this this game has been
incredibly messy it's going backwards and forwards
and even here with three seconds each left i
mean obviously white is pushing for the win but
can black hold this one he's turned down the draw
earlier on um it's been a turnaround this one
every move pretty much this has been absolutely
wild and i mean nihal was winning earlier
hayek was turning this round probably had a
checkmating net missed it and then actually
nihal missed a win with after that queen took on
b3 and i think we'll see a draw it's my best guess
okay but the king can now come yeah say 27 uh
okay yeah quizzes oh no you missed it yeah because
now the king is really good e5 no checks white's
making serious progress here serious progress this
should be winning now before queenie six check
was uh also tempting but uk he's played it now
he can he could find his key to f6 there yes key
of six there's no check yeah and he's done it and
now he's threatening mate in two so this is the
only move queen d8 27 got it this is over this is
over knee house knee has somehow won that one
what a relief that was that was a crazy start
and the game lasted 15 minutes for a you know
five plus one game so you know it went a long time
um i don't even know they let's go back
very quickly just to see those moments where
it felt like hike was the one who was taking
advantage of some mistakes when he brought his uh
knight to um f2 but i don't even know where
that was it's like yeah all the way back here
maybe maybe it was knight e1 that was uh better
i i i wasn't sure like this 91 looks good because
you've got those dual threats you've got queen
gt so g4 is is ruled out in the position oh
but there's queens xd5 there i mean the queen's
stop all the checks all right wow wow whatever
it is it is yeah i guess somehow uh barely holding
on and then towards the end of the game it was
just uh an absolute mess but we're gonna go back
live to this game these players they're under the
pressure trying to figure out all these tactics
with no time on their clock it's really difficult
yeah i say i mean that that first game i i think
it was a bit of a nervous game you know both these
guys obviously have a lot of respect for each
other they must do and uh yeah there was a lot
of nerve showing there but i think they're gonna
they're gonna relax down into their proper play
sort of soon they must be able to do that this
position i suppose is pretty standard robert
white's trying to rely on the two bishops here
in his dark square bishop to get some advantage
yeah that's clearly the gold bishop b2 and say hey
i have the long diagonal and the one thing i don't
like about white's position is the pawn structure
on the queen side here the a4 b3 structure
this bishop on c4 is holding everything together
but if i play bishop e6 and trade off your the
bishops i feel like there's some weaknesses
that you'll have to deal with for a long time
yes it's going to be a trade-off with those that
pawn on b3 probably and white's dark square bishop
if i can try to get that bishop working somehow
um then you know he's going to give him active
play but you're right the pawn the pawn kind
of wants to be back on a2 in some ways but then
you allow b5 uh in the position so it's it's
it's a little bit tricky to get your perfect
setup as white with your pawns on the on the
queen side here that's true yeah i mean bishop e6
comes to mind bishop f5 you want to keep the
bishops on for some reason i would trade i
always feel like when my opponent has the two
bishops removing one of them you know swapping
it off is beneficial for me because then i only
have to worry about one diagonal and not both
yeah i suppose you could consider
knight a5 but actually that knight
might be worth keeping in some ways maybe the
knight is better than your bishop so well okay
knee how's long now gone for the most i'd say
aggressive move um he he's keeping the bishops
on but that pin is a little bit annoying for
hike as well yeah so you just drop back bishop
to h5 and keep it going he says rook d8 okay it
makes sense and he can always take on f3 and then
play knight to e5 if he wants to get the bishop
off the board but there's something about this
situation uh simon it feels like neal doesn't want
to actually take this bishop yeah right i guess
after b takes c4 then it could be black who gets a
little bit of pressure on the b7 pawn or something
um in this position so or he has done it so i mean
queen takes is possible but i like this b takes
um with not root be one now but at some point in
the future possibly right and well big issue is
you can't play bishop b2 because the 52 happens so
maybe white's just a little bit slow at the moment
it does seem that way because how do you get your
bishop in the game rook d2 is coming and um black
has the d file which is very important in such
positions if black can just go root d7 root d8
some simple moves maybe you put the rook on g6
or d6 if you really want to try something uh a
little bit scary it's uh it seems it seems pretty
pretty comfortable for black yeah i actually like
this rook d6 move it felt a little bit more
flexible and you could also put your queen on
d7 so sandwich uh with the queen there on the d
file but he plays rook d7 which was your first uh
suggestion so i guess he just went for the calmer
approach but i did like rook d6 some i think it
gave you more flexibility yeah i guess the
advantage you're putting on d7 you cover the
the be the b7 pawn maybe your queen's a little
bit more active yeah in some variations but with
the rook coming to d8 and white's still not able
to well you can go bishop b2 but do you really
want to allow the rook into d2 and this moves
a bit uglier free i mean uh i see we have ben
feingold in the chat and i know he's a big fan
of f3 and f6 news i don't know i don't know what
he thinks of f3 here i mean with a pawn on h2 it's
much better but it seems a little bit ugly because
you give this g3 square some dark squares maybe
it has to be played but it's not really what you
want to play you're sort of just your pawns are a
little bit weak now i feel completely agreed and
also black's moves feel easy knight g3 is just the
first move it's not really requiring much thought
rook to d8 if you attack my knight i can always
drop it back to h5 if need be i can bring my queen
into h4 to reinforce the knight and also put an
eye on the c4 pawn so i just feel like it's more i
mean knight f5 now as possible right the e pawn is
pinned to the right and then bring my knight into
d4 very nice yeah and he's played it i mean he's
uh both these players amazing positional players
i mean they they know where to put their pieces
and the knight on d4 is now gonna dominate that
bishop and probably white's gonna have to try and
exchange that knight off for his bishop otherwise
there's no way you can get rid of it so all the
advantages seem to be on black side at the moment
and uh knee how playing very well in this game
yeah he's getting off to a good start in the early
stages of both games and right now he plays look
at this what a common move that's very cool could
put my knight on d4 but why don't i just make sure
my king has some love so i don't get checkmated
on the back rank in the future i like that
that's just that's class a petrosian-like move
the the old one yeah so um h6 just giving king
a little bit of safety and and not rushing the
position and now he has to move the knight
here so all right um he played in the ring
bishop to e3 but that's the problem and you
are sort of highlighting this is white's best
opportunity with the bishop is to take the knight
and you know you take the knight you give over
the default or you even allow past pawn straight
away with the pawn replacing the knight there so
white's prospects don't look very good and now i'm
wondering if blacks play f5 to open up new avenues
of attack yeah f5 is a nice move just to try and
uh increase the pressure somehow um i mean white's
a little bit tied down i mean white would like to
maybe try doubling on the b file because the one
target the one only target i can see is this this
pawn on b7 but doubling is going to take a bit of
time and your rooks well you're leaving c4 and
pre so i don't even know if you can do that that
kind of idea here um but how does black improve
probably this f5 idea is correct yeah and i think
important is even behind this knight is the d2
square so like let's say i play f5 and you take
i can even take with my knight because bishop
takes c5 is met by rook d2 and i'm getting a
pretty nice initiative there so just might not be
so easy for white to figure out the consequences
but i actually like the way nihal's doing this is
he's saying you guys keep suggesting moves that
are a little more ambitious i'm going to sit
on the position and ask hike what is your plan
because i don't really see one from white's
perspective here yes i know obviously now f5
is is much stronger because white can't even
take the pawn on f5 because the bishop on e3
and i think this is a very mature way of
playing actually he's just basically saying
okay i i don't need to play f5 or break until
maybe i'll get a better opportunity and it's
it's it's a good way to play this way that's
why white's played this rook to c3 to defend
that bishop again against f5 the queen again he's
just probing here roberts probing those weaknesses
yeah i'm impressed there is something said that
there are players who you know are too solid they
don't go and when the time is right they don't
strike but right now i like what he's doing as
you pointed out the a4 pawn is under attack
he always has this idea of f5 if he wants to
go for it and he can just swing his rook
back to d7 at any moment okay queen e6 so
is he just saying hey let's repeat once
the old russian uh school technique
yeah he did this in the last game a couple of
times when when he was clearly doing very well he
repeated the position once and uh it's well it's
making it it's quite clever idea because you know
you're gaining a little bit of time you can think
in your opponent's time and if you're controlling
the position then you know that if your opponent
tries to do something a little bit different
you're just going to gain some kind of edge
so would he come now back to c6 he has done
and after rook a3 is going to have to try he's
going to have to break at some point i feel though
otherwise how is he going to make progress here
well maybe he doesn't realize that he is the
better oh and it's hayek who plays on with queen
a2 and we do have the benefit i'm not i tried not
to look at it but of course i see the evaluation
bar off to the side i don't have the moves
associated with it but you know we have descent so
we know that black is better here maybe he doesn't
feel like his position is better but he must
right this just looks good for black yes yeah i
mean he's he's got a he's got to do that next step
though so he's got the knights he's got the open
file kind of kind of and what's the next plan um
so everything looks good and whenever he plays the
next plan maybe the position's not going to look
as good you know because he's going to have to
change it and sometimes you don't want to give up
that beautiful looking positions but but you have
to to make progress so he's still waiting but he
has to he has to break somehow otherwise it will
just be a draw maybe he's gonna maybe he's gonna
go knight e6 and you know say well okay you know
i don't need to keep my knight there let's take
the default try to get my pieces around the back
my knight can come back to d4 later on um this is
another way of black playing yeah i'm with you and
i actually like that you know you use the word
probing and that's exactly what he's been doing
he's just making white's life as difficult as
possible with every move no forcing sequences
but just saying hey what's your response gonna
be are you just gonna repeat the position and the
answer has been no thus far hike is not doing that
and now the pawn's in a5 so that's both a strength
and a weakness it's good because it gives you
a plant on b6 to w rooks but it's bad because
hey maybe that pawn just is more vulnerable to
attack and he's done this 96 because his rook you
know the other way apart from playing f5 to try
and do something in this position for black is
to use those rooks and with the rook coming to
d3 and maybe a queen coming to g3 white has to
be very careful the knight can also flip into f4
in some situations if if white ever plays bishop
f2 that that black knight could started a direct
assault against the white king um so i'm expecting
something like rook d3 and i like this very very
patient play from black and we often see this i
think one mistake a lot of players make is when
they have a good position they do want to force
the game they want to force the pace but actually
it's much better to wait for your opponent to make
a mistake even because they're in a comfortable
situation as soon as you force the pace it makes
their decisions a lot easier to make and uh okay
so we've got knight f4 straight away robert yeah
he's saying just like earlier i don't mind trading
off my knight for your bishop and rook to b1 heich
is just not reacting he's just shuffling away but
rook to d3 looks right he doesn't take please take
me on f4 i need to get to the d2 square that's
black's essential goal yeah and you can't move
your rook off the back right because they were in
rook d one check oh the e4 square is now week two
okay well he's he's the the tempo has changed
robert here suddenly white's like right okay
we're down short time i'm gonna i'm gonna push
and pray oh he's blunted he's simply blunted right
that's just this okay it was a tough position
but knee how's patient really really paying off
there and you can see hike on the camera there
looking quite surprised and well i mean he needs
an absolute miracle now being a whole piece
down yeah he would just lean back in his chair
or his couch rather and was just like ugh yeah
what did i do that's the end of that one yeah
brilliant start for nihal brilliant start for the
a very actually knee how's been sort of dominating
both games robert as in he's never well okay got
a bit messy in the first game but positionally
he he's at the moment proving to be the
better player yeah i would say for about
what 90 95 percent of the action we've seen this
far niels had the advantage it may have been
slight in the first game but he's been the one
that's pressing controlling the shots as you were
saying simon so i'm with you i think that neil has
had the better start and it's a big improvement
over his quarterfinal match against anton smirnov
where out of the gate smirnov was up something
like five and a half two and a half something to
that effect so it's a very different nihil that
we're seeing today yes he's playing very well um
and hike really needs to start picking up the pace
because you don't want to be down by a massive
amount at the end of one of these segments and the
other thing is as soon as you start losing a roll
of games you're more likely to lose after that
because you get this negative thinking you get in
the negative oh what's going wrong you might try
to force things you might you might just lose the
plot a little bit so it's horrible when you get on
this role and this is the role i may mention the
start of the match you've got to break out of that
somehow um otherwise it can you can suddenly
just keep losing you know even if you're not
playing that badly your opponent's confidence
also uh becomes greater at the same time uh
solid structure as such though here
yeah um i i will add the problem for
when you face nihal sarin is that some of these
players are not quite as good at bullets so even
if you have a several game deficit and you're the
better bullet player you can make up your ground
but not against neil because he's the highest
rated bowl player on the entire site if i'm not
mistaken and plus good luck to you but in this
game simon i mean i like white's position again i
think that you know you play e4 you just have this
moroxy bind type of situation with these pawns on
c4 and e4 no you're not getting d5 anytime soon
and wow he pushes up on the e5 yeah this is a
very aggressive move and uh this this is this is
actually very i mean i've seen actually sarawan
use this kind of strategy before um black has to
be very careful if he castles because the knight
g5 is sort of a trick you know just just hanging
in the air uh but okay knight takes d4 this d6
square is what white's really aiming for if he can
get a knight cemented into d6 then black will be
facing a lot of problems and he can now do that in
two different ways maybe black has to play f6 and
try to break like that but it's um it's looking
slightly better for nihal yet again here
yeah and this pawn on d7 is a target and the pawn
e5 sort of dominates that pawn you can play d6
but then you need to watch out for queen e4
hitting this rook on a8 and even if you don't
win that row controlling all the light squares is
very important so the knight on h6 is out of play
a very clever sequence by nihal to get that knight
there and if you're playing like yasser sarawan
then hey you're probably playing pretty damn well
yeah yeah little little yasser can we call him uh
will we see him grab some pawns and uh i kind of
like this f6 movie you know even if it doesn't
work because if you're if you're sort of a little
bit worse in these positions i mean we've seen
that hike has kind of suffered by not going active
and at least he's trying to break out of this
grip somehow and create some play on the f-file
backfire it could backfire of course you're sure
that you don't like it just because ben feingold
hates that move well there's other options isn't
there as well you know what i mean uh we even saw
magnus do zooped up f6 didn't we on move one the
other day you know he it's uh but uh i mean it's
it seems to be okay here with the f5 opening but
yeah it does give black it's some benefits here
as you said the f-file opens you also free up your
d-pawn that if you could take on e5 your debunk go
to d6 for example but right now it's an important
moment for nihal he's sitting and thinking can i
just leave the pawn there i'm playing with a to d1
should i take on f6 and be the side who flinches
first should i play rook f to e1 to reinforce
a capture on the e5 square all of those moves
look good to me but i'm not sure which one
is best and he does take on f6 okay so he's
taken here just to relieve the pressure and
again he's he's playing he's playing very solid
nihil very solid chess i mean he's he's not
taking any risks he's he's actually of course
he's a very good tactician but he's kind of uh
saying okay well i i i've outplayed you a little
bit in the last two games i'm going to put my
pieces on these good squares and this might be a
case robert where the central pawn central pawns
are supposed to be better than wing pawns and
you can see that black has two central pawns but
you know that's not always the case and sometimes
when they're on open lines where white can just
place his works to oppose them they can be
more weaknesses than strengths especially
if they're not mobile and those pawns are not
really mobile you can never really push them
too far without them becoming even weaker
so it's still an advantage for white that's
for sure and uncomfortable for black to get his
remaining knight out as well totally with you and
you're absolutely right that in the earlier
stages of the game having the pawns and center
should be good because you're restricting your
opponent's pieces what your pieces want to be
in the center but here that's not the case any
pawn move leaves a huge hole e5 oh give me that
d5 square right i'll just go knight b5 i can
bring my knight into the d5 square if you play
d6 you already drop a pawn but even if you are not
dropping that pawn the c6 square is also becoming
under white's control so you just don't
have the pawn moves that you would like
and those pawns are going to be victim to attack
in the very near future so a6 i mean that's just
kind of a move is he playing rook a7 next maybe
he's going to try b5 it can he play b5 i mean
oh he's gone brook a7 so he wants to put it
on c7 this is this is and then maybe he wants
to go knight c6 so he can try to take with a
rook but it's uncomfortable for blackness very
uncomfortable it's a slow approach where even if
you get like let's say i give you those two free
moves you go rook c7 96 all at once then what i
take you on c6 you still have to take with your
pawn because the rook is needed to defend the
d7 square so knight c6 i just take and you'd
have to take with the pawn you lose e6 anyway
oh this is just no fun i mean it's i mean the
way knee how is playing as well i mean okay he's
kind of making hike i'm not gonna say look bad but
look bad a little bit but he's and he's not bad
he's he's a fantastic player he's over 3000 but
nihal is just keeping control and he's doing the
same strategy now as he did in the last game where
when he has that little bit of control when
black can't move his knight he's not rushing
if he can improve his position a little bit he
will he's getting ready to double his rooks and
he's just being very patient in the position it's
a really clever clever strategy he's using so far
and i think it's a great one and actually hike
tends to have a pretty similar style it's like
a binding style where you limit your opponent's
possibilities in the sense that most moves are
you have some downside to them here like rook c5
is played where's that rook going can't go to f5
to join the queen so it just it moved on out but
what next for me how i'm thinking do i play a4
do i maybe go knight h2 knight g4 at some point
just to does that really improve the location man
i'm not sure but i can do what i want because
i don't really see what blacks maybe knight h2
is bad because e5 happens i might play my favorite
move here i was going to say h4 i was going to say
yeah i mean again i like this move because you're
just slowly improving it it might not seem like
you're doing much but if you if you're if you
can make sure that your opponent can't improve
their position you you know you force the weakness
here i i would say the two moves h4 h6 have helped
white potentially g6 is now a hole for for a
white piece and it's showing this extreme patience
um and again a lot of people watching the show
you know one thing i would say about you know
lower rated players that they can improve on the
most is uh looking at your opponent's ideas and
when you realize that they're actually struggling
to find a plan you'll realize that you don't have
to force something you can play these like moves
and sort of say right i'm waiting for my opponent
to to do something dodgy while i'm improving so
this is this is really really patient play and
nice play it certainly is and it's funny because
uh nihal is playing like both of us i said a4 you
said h4 and he said why not both that's how much
time he has in this position he does and and king
h8 kind of shows that black can't do much i mean
i don't think he's ever going to try rook g8 and
g5 that seems i mean can he play it maybe but
you know this is the kind of thing i was talking
about that you're kind of tempting your opponent
into just making these kind of rash moves by by
showing extreme patience but uh is he going to
go g5 what do you reckon will he will he punt it
i think that just it makes your position closer
to losing than you know anything beneficial but
what else can he do i mean what really what else
can you do here yeah is he just gonna go king
jake king h8 and say right me how it's up to you
you can't just wait here and torture me forever
um you've got to try to do something maybe
that's maybe that's what he's going to do
he's decided he can't do anything else because
it will make his position worse so he's going to
he's going to bide his time it's really not fun
playing like that though so it's not fun but it
actually might be objectively the best idea like
what does rook for sure is he what did that move
i i again i i i don't know i'll be honest okay
so now now black has actually made a decision
um with knight e5 and this okay so this decision
this decision has it helped black or is it helped
white i mean to me it still still seems like black
is uh okay so he's trying to now get his some
freedom right right and knight f3 there's rook f5
watch out that's a big problem down the f1 because
the rook and queen are perfect you just want one
more attacker in there so don't play knight f3
can you play f4 is that too much i mean for if
it works therefore it's definitely a good move
because uh oh he's got okay so he's got knight
of three is he gonna repeat the position like
knight d okay he's doing that he's doing the
tactic again he's he's just he's just squeezing i
squeeze you i squeeze you but he he's after brook
f5 okay is he black can't really be thinking he
should play for a win here i mean that'd be crazy
he's got to go rook f5 yeah he's gonna go back
but now is this a draw it's a draw yeah he's
a draw i was gonna say that that that was very
that like that was very strange because niihau
okay maybe nihal didn't realize that his position
was that good there yeah i actually just looked
at their faces and he didn't really seem upset by
the draw so even if he was much better there and
we thought that he should play on he didn't seem
too okay okay so he's still got the lead two
and a half to half so it's still going knee
how's way and one thing i i think a good comment
in the chat and i'm just keeping an eye on uh
twitch.tv slash chess com events um for any chat
that's going on and i think it was made by steph
594 and he was basically saying that smirnoff's
uh actually that's the vodka isn't it smirnoff
okay yeah smell of trickiness in the trickiness
that he played with his tactical ideas and the
aggressive approach was causing um knee how many
more problems and this solid approach that that
hike's adopting but it is his style to play play
in this manner but maybe nihal's very well suited
for this this manner yeah i think stylistically
these two players are actually quite similar they
want to uh just get a solid position for
themselves where there are no tactical
opportunities for their opponent and they want to
slowly outplay out maneuver uh the the other side
and we see the catalan and you know vladimir
kramnik is somewhere watching this and like oh
please make me proud uh young guys and what is
this pun on a5 simon i mean this a4 a5 you are
gaining space but i'm not really too familiar
with this plan i'm certainly no expert myself in
the catalan i'm i mean i guess the whole idea of
the a5 pawn is kind of this weird minority attack
where you're using the the a and b pawn to try
and tie up black's c being a pawn so if black
ever moves the b pawn you you can take on pass on
and create some weaknesses in black's position so
it's sort of a a space gaining tire upper if
that's their terminology i don't know if it is but
um yeah uh okay well that that's the position has
now changed somewhat yeah it's bit well now the a
pawn looks very good to me okay it's funny because
now that black is the only side of the dark square
bishop i'm like is it maybe potentially bad
but i'm thinking well down the road like if
i can trade queens then maybe i can go after
this a pawn right easily he's going for it
potentially right now bishop c7 putting his
eye on it but actually i'm with you simon i
think that white's position is becoming a bit
more favorable the knight on d3 is particularly
good you can go to c5 if that bishop ever moves
but i guess that bishop is here to stay on d6
yeah i mean it's a very solid structure for both
players here and uh the one problem with placing
that port on a5 as well another problem is that
white can't do the minority attack with b4 b5
and in these positions the move b4 b5 is a
standard way to attack on the queen side of
pawn and a4 so um i'm kind of thinking and
i love h5 h5 is again starting sort of some
wing action on the other board maybe even i'm
preferring black somewhat here because of the
easier plan of attack white can't attack on
the queen side black can on the king side
and uh with the knight coming to g4 at some moment
it looks it looks very pleasant actually and we
should talk about opposite colored bishops in
games we often think oh it's just a draw because
they're working on other diagonals but when you
have the potential of an attack having opposite
color bishops is a good thing for the attacking
side because i can go after the dark squares
you can't defend them yeah i mean white's done
the best he can by placing his knight on c5 but
that that that king of his you know it can
certainly come to to some kind of harm and
you have this knight g4 and i like g6 you
can even go king g7 rook h8 right and and i
i just feel that white's kind of planned us
here without the minority attack of going
b4 b5 so this a4 a5 plan seems incorrect is he
going to go for e4 now is this is this something
here he's thinking i can't sit here i have to do
something here yeah i think this is a plan more of
desperation than of aggression and it's a good one
and it's a good lesson for a lot of our viewers
when you are attacked sometimes you need to break
open something else so that you can counter and
here breaking open the center will mean that black
can't just go rook h8 rook h7 other rook to h8 and
just go mate the white king i will play e4 and
now you'll have to deal with some of my threats
i do think that this is a good idea all things
considered but i still really really like the
l's position yeah i i mean you don't you don't
really want to defend passively and so far for
um this hasn't worked for hike in the match he's
kind of sat and waited and that's why he's only
got half a point so with the idea of maybe going
rookie one at least he's keeping nihal thinking
about this e4 move and you and this is a bit
annoying because you've got to constantly keep
an eye on it when that rook swings away from e8
you lose control of e4 so that's probably the
time white will will aim to hit in the center of
the board i i definitely agree with that and i'm
wondering for black do you play knight e4 yourself
to plant essentially a pawn once you capture me
on e4 to stop your forward progress and if you
take with the knight on e4 this b4 pawn is a
target so i'm wondering if i can play knight
e4 pawn f5 and just try to close the center
as quickly as possible before rerouting you know
to the king side with rocket ship yeah it seems
like a very good plan actually knight e4 um it
stops white's one plan as well which is always
quite pleasant if your opponent's got a plan you
can stop it you're doing that thing where you're
just you know keeping them under control and
frustrating them into into making a mistake so
yeah i really like knight e4 will he play i mean
he has been so patient maybe he doesn't want to
play he can be overly patient you have to do
something at some point um and i s he might
be thinking can i improve my position without
changing the structure uh and it's not easy to
do so i think i mean rooks rook h8 e4 if e4 works
then you shouldn't be going for rook h8 of course
because you're sort of just you're showing your
hand and you're just very clearly going for the
king-side attack and if i start trading some
pieces you won't even have much of an attack
and it's not like black will be in huge danger
there but with the king on g7 maybe that diagonal
will open up and he says let me first take on
g3 and think about the rest a little bit later
yeah i mean i i i wouldn't personally have taken
on g3 because unless you have a solid follow-up
because you want to have the move h3 and in some
positions and you're limiting your possibilities
and it's always best to keep as many possibilities
as you can i don't think white has ever taken your
pawn so it seems just a very small thing but
giving yourself a possibility of playing pawn
h4 to h3 it is a nice extra bonus and it's these
kind of things which will lose your advantage
if you keep doing it but he's played your plan
robert he's put the knight into e4 which is uh
making progress like you say f5 coming and then
you can play rook to h8 was certainly an attack
against white's king still and you also have
to be careful knight takes f2 or knight takes
g3 there are sacrifices that now hike needs to
keep his eye on and i think he made a really
instructive point there about the leaving the pawn
h4 i also would have left that pawn there for the
time being because it didn't feel like white could
do anything about it but i guess nihal saying hey
very directly i have this under control and still
white has little that he can do to fend him off
yes i mean you know if black can just improve and
white what can white do here because you haven't
got this b5 move this this pushing the pawn
away five it just didn't work very well he's
come back now which is it is he doing that he's
done this before isn't he where he's basically
saying i've got to sit here and wait and now there
is certainly knight g3 but you only play knight g3
if it works because you have a good position
anyway but does it work i mean it's tempting
certainly tempting simon i always sacrifice
people's pieces you know when i'm commenting right
just let me do it knight g3 pawn takes bishop
g3 at the very least you have two pawns for the
sacrifice knight e3 is weak h1 i mean how many
times you can tap me into it how many times yes
and also i mean you could go queen g5 first then
you're really getting ready then aren't you i mean
with the queen on g5 it it's it's got
the trigger's gonna be pulled there
yeah quenching five is better i think that's
objectively a much better move um i do like the
look of knight takes g3 i like it less than that
the queen can come over to g2 but you're right
simon just the calmer approach queen g5 it's not
really that calm you're threatening to sacrifice
things for okay go for checkmate well not too soon
don't play rogue h8 yet because then e6 is yes
and the world taking on g3 and so he has to give
up that bishop but that bishop is such a good
defender of the king and we're all like i mean
this is again if if black had a pawn on h4 here
if we just you know you could go h3 and put the
queen on f3 so for example that that exchange but
okay even this position it must be good i mean
it's practically so hard to defend do you play
with rook f3 or do you play rook hey i'm not
sure here well navigating yeah oh never never
yeah maybe rookie rookie seven first
i guess yeah queen five is a good move
because you give yourself the control over
e6 and the potential for all directions but
maybe hike is defending this i don't really
see a way forward at least not that easily for
black uh maybe rook f7 rook f8 but can't white
also play like rook h four and then i guess i
don't have time to double as white that's the
problem yeah i mean white if white can double
on the h5 it's white who's going to take over the
initiative and he's done a good he's definitely
done a good defensive job here he's uh he's done
the best he can white um to get this structure
so but he's going to have to play rook f1 and
he's going to have to wait here so i don't think
black still i still like black but it might
there might not be a way to break through
easily here yeah actually i think that why is
things pretty well under control because you
can't pile up any more pressure on the f2 maybe
you should put your king on like d8 and then
then you can sort of uh put your rook on f3
actually not d8 put it on e7 i just want to i
want to go queen g5 and rook f3 and not not lose
my queen uh so but that's that's not not easy to
achieve so i i do like the idea of the the king
walk though right that's the i i think but now
okay the time now this is this is actually and now
that that's come off it seems like white should be
absolutely fine so so knee house just with this
exchange basically saying okay i can't be better
anymore and can white be better though here can is
white now okay so he's gone here and the b pawn is
weak so it's probably a draw right robert
because there's no way he can get through but
there could be some like rugby one king h3 king
oh he's not like right away no that looked bad
and rugby one oh this is really bad now really bad
yeah even rook h8 rook h1 is is coming yeah and
he's pulled one back brilliant defense looking for
a six check bam beautiful thank you for the game
yeah and now you just got to calculate e4 probably
best here i think is that right just to get the
passport yeah okay and king g4 just king e3 you
you lose your f1 it's very very simple very nice
well that i have to say a very impressive
game from height day he got himself a little
bit of trouble um he defended in that game
brilliantly and he he really needed that win
uh in a position where he was certainly a bit
worse and um i think nihal's gonna be very upset
with that one from from his positional play maybe
this is the turning point robert where hike can
get a bit of a role going yeah actually it's two
games in a row there where you know niall started
up two to nothing then they drew game three but
of course hike's position was very bad in that
game so surviving game three probably gave hike
a bit more confidence he had a bad position in
game four a worse position it wasn't that terrible
but it didn't look very good and he not only held
that but won the game so yeah you start feeling
a lot better you can take a breath saying hey
i'm not just going to get dominating this match
yes it's not getting your first win on the board
is so important because uh you know you you will
you can get demoralized of course you can it's
it's a mental game so now now he can relax
a bit more and play as normal stuff and this
is quite a solid variation of the slav defense
knight b6 a relatively sort of modern idea um
and it's it's now a standard position where free's
normal right rockets yeah i was wondering what
took him so long to make that move because
f3 phobia e4 is quite typical but knight d7
played immediately by hike so it seems like
hike knows what he's doing and maybe nihal is
caught off guard yes possibly i mean i think one
line here okay has taken that one he could have
gone to e4 anyway but he's again going for any
risk-free strategy where he's not allowing black
to take on e5 himself um with the pawn coming
to b4 black's probably gonna break with e5 this
is black's idea some something like that so it
doesn't get too uh too uncomfortable for space
yeah that's that would seem to be reasonable
and it's interesting to me simon that now hike
is thinking about how to recapture so either right
this is just a inaccurate move by nihal or haiku
is bluffing to some extent where he doesn't really
know the ins and outs of this line yeah i mean
i i guess the knight on b6 is is a bit problematic
now that's why maybe knight takes d7 and some e5
idea could have been uh a more a better way to
play i don't know the theory here but that knight
is is is wobbly and black hasn't castled you know
white's got the center i i like white's position
here a lot so do i and i'm looking at harry the
h pawn thinking h4 is a movie as well like why
can't i just push on both sides of the board here
exactly do the same as you did before right h4 and
a4 get get them moving and okay so now you've got
to think about d5 does is d5 working or not uh you
don't i mean so far knee has been very patient and
he hasn't wanted to change the structure when he's
got like a small advantage but this i like i like
that he's played this now because i think it's you
know i was getting a bit worried he's being too
patient you got to push at the right time and this
this must be the right move to play it just feels
totally right oh yeah you can even follow with
bishop to c4 because you can never take with the
c pawn the c pawn is needed to keep uh the piece
out of b5 as soon as you take on d5 here comes
bishop b5 winning your queen so maybe bishop c4
in other movies you could place queen d4 and then
just gain space in the center and stop that bishop
from developing because you're attacking the pawn
on g7 so actually 24 is surprisingly annoying
yeah because the the only plan black's
got here is to move the bishop in f8 and
get castled and if he can do that if he can get
castle he's okay so i really like your queen d4
queen d4 stopping your opponent's plan and this
this is uh aiming for a small advantage but i felt
that white could have aimed for more with uh with
black's king being in the worst situation there
because white can castle quickly swapping queens
off it's going to give white something definitely
there's no doubt about that without pawn
on c6 but it's not a big advantage anymore
the other positional problem though black does
have here which often occurs in this variation
is that bishop on g6 i mean i'm not a master
of the theoretical side but the bishop on g6
is a really horrible piece because it's blocked
out by white's pawn structure so this these are
the problems black has here yeah and this what's
going to happen is in addition to what simon was
just saying is you're going to take back on c6
once white takes this queen and interesting that
nihal is sitting here really trying to figure out
how to capture back because it's king on c2 for
this very reason what i was about to say is you
have a semi-open b file for the black rook and
that pawn on b2 is a backwards pawn so you could
get in some trouble there and the b4 square he
just put his bishop there i would much prefer if i
could get my knight to that square somehow here we
come here comes our friend harry and uh i think
that moves h4 h5 definitely help white because
i was thinking black might try this f5 move
or something the f pawn and then then it sort
of weakened his structure by playing h5 um knee
how playing very sensible good moves this is his
strategy just play good moves nothing particularly
flashy it's a good strategy though isn't it robert
something something i should probably uh try more
myself in my games you know i was like can he
teach us because uh he's making it look easy and
you it is we're right from the very start of this
match where hike is an amazing player and nihal
is just like clearly to me being the better of the
two just today not overall classical rating feed
a wise they're about the same it's i think they're
both in the 26 20s incredibly talented players
but in this match after four games i have felt
the power of neil he's been really dictating the
course of the games and here is no exception to
that his position is better with white he has
obtained a pull here and i would think about
playing h5 to force this bishop back all the way
to h7 because the bishop doesn't look so thrilled
to be sitting in front of the rook out there yeah
i agree with everything you said there robert and
um it does seem like nihal's on on form and one
of the biggest skills is actually i mean uh making
a game look easy and uh a lot of people sort of
including myself i do like the sacrificial games
my favorite world champion being like macau tau
but i really appreciate the players who make chess
look easy like mickey adam's english grandmaster
springs to mind when you watch his games you
kind of well i kind of think well what did he
do there what did he do he didn't do anything
impressive there but he just crushes 2700s by
doing nothing impressive oh what's this move okay
so the knight is trying to get a bid for freedom
and making chess look easy is is so hard to do
it really is yeah actually i say this often that
uh people asking which players inspired you you
know who are your favorite players michael adams
since i was a kid is one of my favorite players
100 and it's because of executing i would look
at his games and be like what did his opponent do
wrong like how did he win and win in 35 moves with
white seemingly without doing much of anything
and another player like that is lanier dominguez
i watch okay he plays the sustain in some sharper
lines but oftentimes i see him just grind people
down and i look i'm like wait what that was like
a nothing game but he wins and he makes it look
like his opponent was 200 points lower rated
than he actually is yeah yes when you're not sure
and i mean when you when you lose a game yourself
like if i lose a game and i know i've done
something wrong it's like okay uh i i i can
sort of get over that in the future but when
i've played mickey adams before and i lost
the game i'm like hanging me i don't think i did
anything wrong there how did i lose and i'm like
wow and i'm like and it really confuses me and i'm
like don't do that to me it's not fair you know
don't show your strength so much and it's
like wow you know it's really impressive he's
really impressed me so go check him out if you
don't know him uh mickey adams is games so yeah
honestly players like they just make you feel
like you don't understand chess and that's
such a bad feeling it's like wait wait i have this
title next to me that's a grand master title but
you just made me feel like i i'm learning the
game anew it's honestly refreshing and that's
why i love studying their games and niall starring
right now he could try to do that with the white
piece in this game because now that black is
castled but this bishop is stuck out here on h7
you have to like white's chances here so
grind uh hiked out yeah certainly i mean
you know black has this one idea of trying to
do something on the b file but um this is very
easy to defend and black's pawn structure
is worse the pawn on a5 the pawn on c6
both potential targets and i think nihal was
trying to go 92 maybe knight d4 just trying to
find somewhere for that knight it's one idea um
i also quite like the idea of just going g4 but
maybe he doesn't want to give away some squares
there uh he's very patient look at this bishop e2
just attacking the knight just you know very very
sort of simply sort of saying what are you doing
and now he comes to c4 so that the bishop can't
be attacked i mean that is some maneuvering there
i mean that is so subtle guys i mean robert that's
it that's really really you know special i feel
he knows he wants his bishop on c4 but bishop c4
right away would have been it by knight e5 hitting
the bishop and the pawn so he retreats his bishop
first and then oh that's just wonderful play there
and black is trying to make progress himself he's
attacking the pawn on a b3 here i play rook to b1
which is a very nihal type of move right just like
quiet don't take on c5 yet if i don't really have
to he may okay he does take on c5 but rook do
you want it how can we go he's got to watch his
time hasn't he again i mean i know he's very
quick and uh he has given up the bishop player
robert but the bishop on h7 it's not a big deal
i i feel the bishop on h7 is is really bad um
but he's got to just keep an eye on his clock you
know you can you can forget about it yeah and the
the look at the difference in the rooks here that
works in the d file that can go into d7 the rooks
in the b file you're staring into a protected pawn
on b3 so just a much bishop a6 okay i hung the
b3 bomb so i was just saying how you're staring
at nothing but if i move my bishop way too soon
you get me what about this yeah i i think he's
going to try to find a good square for his knight
and if you can get his knight to c4 somehow then
uh that that seems like a good square because he's
got he doesn't really want to move his pawns i
feel black's maybe not doing anything so how do
you get it to c4 uh not easily maybe knight b1 is
this the knee how move you know knight b1 d2 c4 uh
that's the kind of thing i would okay i expect me
how to play okay black's done something drastic
though he's done something drastic yeah and
i think e5 as well just to trade the bishops
and bring my knight into e4 so sure oh very nice
yeah very nice this is a much simpler way to play
and you do get rid of the bad bishop of blacks
but you you gain this i mean now you split black
spawns on the king side as well um five seconds
oh my gosh you need more quickly this could be
very bad and now the king is coming this is where
hike's dangerous when he starts to sniff that
activity and he's very good at getting oh look at
that by neil the king is running right up the c
file oh nice move nice idea oh my gosh that was
like a e5 only try yeah very nice little bit yeah
i thought that hike was about to you know take
this one honestly and then he overlooks 96 check
and just here comes the very easy moves can you
see five king takes e6 yes uh that king f5 is just
premature and he didn't use his time advantage
well there i mean actually in some respects
you know this is a big mistake you can do over
the board as well and the big mistake is you can
play badly in your opponent's time trouble and in
that situation it was hike who blundered in his
opponent's time trouble and uh this is actually
an easy win you get your rook behind the past pawn
there's no way you can just stop the simple plan
that robs pointed out he's trying something he's
got to try something right yes and he's
hoping oh he's no time let me you know
try to trick him swindle him here but you
can read david smith's book on swindles all
you want you're not going to get this one
you have to have a very big swindle here
super swindle because uh yeah here it goes and
king east but this pawns are actually a little
bit more annoying than i mentioned credit for it's
he's doing his best and making this a little bit
okay nice that is beautiful he's done it again
little bit of a very nice end game play these
little moves which are sort of just to push
your opponent's pieces off side and uh that's
wonderful if e2 you go rookie one and now this
one is going to simply win those black pawns
you want to check and then you get your
queen a rook you want same idea queen me
thank you wow he has i mean the way
he turned that around but it honestly
was hike's fault we'll pull up the analysis
board just very quickly to show that position
uh where i mean knight d6 check happened and
then it all went south so at this point here
instead of king f5 something you're right
just think a little bit maybe rook b8
and just avoid 96 so that you can even
bring your rook to the king side with h4
it makes a lot of sense because white's pawns are
on those dark squares and that h4 move is a great
lever to to to weaken them and i think hike would
have been very much in the game there especially
using that time advantage in a sensible
way if he if he hadn't played his king king
f5 blunder and that's big i mean how much time do
we have left we have half an hour left roberts and
we we kind of thought that you know this might be
actually a segment where hike has to kind of win
because we put nihao at being the stronger player
slightly in the in the bullet i mean there's not
much between these guys but nihal is is really
really jumping ahead and it's three and a half one
and a half already yeah it's a super impressive
start for him and in this game this is a little
bit odd to me knight h5 bishop g5 it has in to
some extent a king's indian vibe but it's from the
italian game so f5 is probably on the docket
that's what you know we'll try to uh organize
here move his king away from the g8 square
but this is this is strange to me yeah i mean
i'm not an expert on these structures at all and
certainly not on this structure i don't know it's
a very unique way to play but they do say that the
dark square bishop of blacks is often a bad piece
because you know like a king's indian it can
be a bad piece stuck behind a pawn on e5 so
positionally speaking you know trying to trying
to get rid of that bishop makes sense um and
with the knight coming into f4 uh i i was
going to say i like black's position but i i
i think it's kind of normal black white's
white hasn't done anything wrong here so
again white can't be doing badly surely so you're
saying we should call it mickey adams because
you know he hasn't done anything wrong but
sometimes the game ends even when it feels
like that's the case that's it yeah i
mean get mickey on the dog and blower
that's the phone if anyone's not sure what
that means um well rookie one i guess he's
just going to try to get the knight to f1 in
standard standard fashion like this and the case
okay you want to play d4 for white but right now
black has too many attackers on the square yeah
and is is black is black gonna try to okay i was
gonna say black could go super aggressive with g5
and try to get g you know h5 g4 but i don't like
this with the f5 square it looks anti-positional
sometimes when you push a pawn um you have to
remember every pawn move you you make weakens a
square you know and pushing the g pawn because f5
and h5 and you just got to make sure your opponent
can't take advantage of those and that that seems
like a positional mistake actually i want to be
aggressive robert you know me i want to push i
want i want to give them a push so should we start
with h5 perhaps and that way you're waiting on
why but white's move is going to be 93 regardless
so h5 doesn't actually help against that threat
yeah and i i guess if white can swap off safely
that knight on f4 or kick it back with g3 then
it's actually gonna be black's pieces which
which look funny you can't do g3 easily
now knight to g1 is another source is that
another idea they play in these positions to
play g3 again it looks really odd to me um
but okay bishop g bishop b5 interesting robert i
i guess he's looking at the d4 square because he
moved bishop b5 instantly there wasn't even a
moment's thought there but now i'm liking your
g5 edit assignment because white's pieces have
shifted away from the king side and blacks have
come towards the king side so g5 feels just about
right at this point it's a very practical move
isn't it i mean in this time limit it's much more
fun to attack we haven't seen nehal go for these
kind of attacks so he's doing it in more knee
how style just putting his pieces on good squares
not you know not not committing to a pawn move
that might weaken a square it's very again it's
it's so mature we're playing but i don't think i'd
be able to resist pushing those king side pawns
in the position i think they'd be launched a
couple of moves ago like this is a position
where we're looking at g5 he'll be like let
me play king g7 first you know be preemptive
so that uh i can play g5 next if i need to or
you know play h5 he oh you've done it yeah come
at on at last he's put he he's decided it's
time to have a go so uh so is this a good
move or a bad move that that's that's what we're
going to find out very soon right it looks to me
like it's a good move because this knight on e7
can come to g6 and then watch out for sacrifices
over there on g2 and f2 is what i'm looking
at h5 as well right this does resemble one
of my favorite my favorite openings the black
the so-called black line which uh is this kind
of very dangerous club player opening where you
play like the the sort of this this setup with
black with a knight on f4 and you just try
to blow white away by playing by playing h5
g4 and um again it's whoever's the other thing
in chess is you don't necessarily always have to
have the advantage to have the better chances you
have to have the position that is easier to play
and even if the position is slightly worse
here if your position is easier to play it's
you know quicker time limits even more so that
gives you that better practical game computers
won't tell you this but black's position is
easier to play here certainly not a thousand
percent in agreement especially in a blitz game
you know if you talk about classical chess then
it's like you have to really think about the
consequence of your actions but in blitz your
opponent is often just feeling insecure about
their king safety when there's a knight in f4
pawns storming down the board here and knight g1
you had mentioned this move simon it allows for g3
it also opens up the queen to the h5 pawn and
the g4 square so g4 not so easy to accomplish
but i'm looking at this i'm saying wait why can't
i not play g4 you take on g4 queen h4 check and
that probably just would be the game that's
scary yeah okay would he play g4 well g4 is is is
the move you certainly want to play anyway and as
robert you pointed out that that allows the black
queen over to h4 has he seen this if he's if he's
seen this idea he will play it you know it's it's
he's of course he's seen it he's playing so well
of course he's seen it why don't i even question
the house it's ridiculous to question him you know
people people overlook things every now and then
and i think we should point out and i was about to
say that g3 is often a move played by white giving
up the h3 pawn because after g3 knight h3 knight
takes pawn takes a situation like this arises
where it looks like black has an extra pawn but
that's not what's important rook f1 white can just
strike back with f4 and it's white who has a much
better position despite black's extra pawn on h3
yeah that pawn on h3 is typical it's actually
better having one of your opponents pawns
on that square than your own pawn they say when
you're being attacked because your opponent's pawn
blocks your king better because they can't your
opponent can't capture their own pawn but he can
capture one of your pawns in front of your king so
that you know it's a very good defensive mechanism
there of allowing your your opponent to put a pawn
in front of your king tucking your king behind it
and you can use it as a blockade a hundred percent
true and here this is the case if white plays h4
black is immediately sacrificing the knight he's
not thinking about that surely no way and is black
going to play f5 as well can we just bring all of
our forces into the attack well i think he wants
to he wants to play f5 and just open it up so
white didn't play this movie okay so f5 is kind of
is critical here uh i feel yeah just going for
it and he's played it he's played it without
any this is the thing when you've won a couple
of games you're much more confident you can see
that nihal's playing very confidently here with
these moves on the king's side he's a confident
guy anyway i mean you should be at that age
it's when when you get to our rage robert the
doubts start creeping in you know yeah you know
you know am i really able to win this game but
he no he of course he is just an amazing
player and he knows it but in this moment
this could be a chance for him because i'm looking
at the clock and it's a complex position and hikes
a little bit ahead and it feels like nihal is
more prone to getting himself into time travel
yeah well this is a big question should have
should have uh of bishop takes that f5 being
played because that is a pawn on g4 if white can
win the pawn he will win the pawn and uh niehaus
now got the question to answer i mean he's got
some play on the h-file uh by sacrificing that
pawn with you know maybe he should have gone king
g7 earlier robert right because if he had gone
king g7 earlier and this same kind of mess that
occurred it it would have rook to h8 in a lot of
positions but um you know maybe maybe actually you
well because you said king you said maybe knight
h6 is a clever move here because i'm giving you my
pawn on h5 but i'll throw in a knight g4 check and
so uh oh that is me asking did he just take on
short now i clicked on the square but i wanted
to play knight h6 and then give up a pawn you
said before you know if you it's your opponent's
pawn there you can end up capturing it but he
goes for this trade and what is happening here
well it seems like white's over the
worst but black has an initiative um
in this position but i mean uh
does he have an initiative i mean
i guess he's got to get a rook to
h8 and then the white king sits on
g2 but the time again you're right this time this
time's going to make it very tricky for knee hell
because if you don't find the right way to play
this position then you're just worse and um
does he have a good move now how about knight
g7 with a queen can i take on g6 queen h3 this
is getting well it's good it's got three seconds
he's got to move he's got to move okay now that
could just be over right yeah that is that is over
here okay wow that that went downhill very quickly
for me how so i mean really well played by height
too again his defensive skills have proven to be
quite impressive at the moment to keep
himself in this match and he's he should win
this one now yeah he's of a piece and he's
using his time wisely which he did not do
in the previous game where he led that 96 check
so that was a good pause by hike so that he could
just convert his winning position yeah so white's
a piece up and white's also got this very clever
knight g5 move rook h1 so it's nice being a piece
up when you have the attack as well and what he's
going to be two pieces up there so that was a
really important game there uh for hike robert
i think to get back into knee house seemed to play
very well but he he he spent a lot of time and he
didn't find the right blow later on yeah he's
just been doing that in several games now where
he's had a good position or promising position and
yes it's super complicated he's trying to figure
out the exact right move but he's getting himself
in too much time trouble to finish the game off so
i do think that hike has proven very sturdy in
time trouble situations for the most part and neil
of course does the lead but i would keep an eye on
that simon especially as we get into quicker time
controls yeah i mean nihal's gonna have to up the
pace in the next game i mean the next segment the
free three minute segment um and let's remember
if hayek now wins this game he's leveled the score
he's leveled the score so it's kind of
pretty much standard position where white's
meant to be a little bit better because this
is one case where the central pawns are good
if you can remember us talking about central pawns
being weak before in this situation as robert
pointed out those pawns grab a lot of squares
and white can sort of put his pieces behind them
and they sort of uh can slowly move forward so
it's certainly a little advantage of white but
black's going super solid here right maybe maybe
we've seen the game that nihal lost there was
when knee how didn't go solid maybe hype should
be trying to get nihal out of these super solid
positions that'd be my little bit of advice you
know try to mix it up a little bit more against
knee hell um that that would be you know if i was
there able to give hike advice that's what i'd say
and that was actually one of the comments
you read earlier was saying just as much
as smirnov gave nihal some issues because
he was playing more tactical positions and
tricky in a sense and here hike keeps going to
these very not casual positions but more closed
positions where you're looking at the little
pawn breaks rather than any kind of sacrifice so
the last game was different because that did get
tactical and nihal spent too much time and here we
have just a nice little positional advantage for
white with a rook on d1 and a queen on d8 the rook
almost always wins that battle yes well okay so
c5 has been played and the rook went to d1 to try
to stop such a break as this but um you have to
now take the bishop you'd rather take the knight
and now okay night knight comes in there's some
knight h7 stuff it looks like right and you've
got knight e4 as well that's the positionally sort
of founding of it just to centralize that knight
at the same time yeah i'll just show
very quickly like if you play rook to e8
i can i think just take your pawn on h7
because after we trade everything out here
i have queen d3 check winning the knight on d7 not
defended so yeah i can win a pawn in that manner
right so rookie also doesn't make too much
sense but just trying to show one of white's
ideas tactics so h6 was played and just
kicking that one away and now centralizing
the d6 square is white for the taking you can take
this bishop on c5 for the two bishops advantage
i definitely prefer nihal's position i
think he does too because he's well ahead
in the clock yeah i mean one thing he's
always got here he can i mean he doesn't
maybe want to grab the bishop on c5 because
suddenly black's knight on d7 comes to life
uh we talk about the advantage of the two
bishops but you don't always you know you
don't always want to do that you know sometimes
the knight can be better here um i mean it's
not i mean this is a standardish position black
can't be doing that badly either here uh white
what what's white doing can you get a king side
attack i mean again i'm always looking at the
king this is one of my problems i need so i need
to i need to grow up a little bit and play like
knee hell i need to play like my juniors not
my seniors not from the juniors not the seniors
and but i mean something i'd be thinking of
here's rook ac1 bishop b1 queen c2 but maybe
it doesn't even do anything but you know just
like getting that diagonal towards black's king
probably a better way to play though that does
make sense and also i'm looking at d6 square can
i throw in knight d6 right now because to somebody
like wait you're just giving me a free piece but
just to of course show you that you can't take on
d6 without losing your queen i said rook always
wins the stair down with the queen bishop h7
check gets rid of the bishop and thank you for
the queen so knight d6 is a move that you can
consider here it doesn't really do much it attacks
the bishop the bishop can just move away so i'm
also you need to grow up for my one with threats
well we all love we all love the cheapo don't
we i mean unfortunately we're kind of trained
well you know we're taught from a young age
get don't go for scholars mate because it's
stupid but we all love a cheapo everyone loves a
cheapo you know no matter what age you can't get
out of that habit and i certainly can't if i see
a little cheapo i'm very tempted to give it a go
um but you should never do cheapos it makes
your position worse this is a big problem that
i again i think lower rated players play they
they play sort of um tricky moves and they're
hoping their opponent doesn't find the right
answer you should always assume your opponent's
going to find the right move always it's the only
way to improve even if you get your cheap hosing
and i i just saw the uh evaluation bar shoot in
black's favor after this a4 move because after b4
i wonder if um missed that for a5 there's just
queen c6 and there's a checkmate threat down on g2
in addition to uh the knight on c3 being under
attack so essentially a5 queen c6 you would like
to take on f6 with check but after the knight
takes back you can't block my checkmating threat
down on g2 and your knight is in trouble yeah
that's that's a nice plan that one and all of a
sudden that means black might be gaining in the
digital because white has to take on f6 and put
his knight on this bad square okay if that knight
gets to c4 he's okay but black has the activity
this might be his chance to try and do something
before white can uh play these two moves so he's
done it queen c6 threatening mate good move don't
wonder that one uh so don't play knight to d2 you
need to protect the actual g2 square f3 weakens e3
and may allow knight d5 move so queen f1 said but
yeah this is looking really good for
black now because white's pieces are
are just not really sitting pretty and is he just
is he just giving that pawn he does yes okay i i
would definitely take it and wouldn't think too
long ago he does take it and i think white is
even forced to trade the queens two bishops
and now the bishop on d5 look at that piece
that's a lovely piece i mean now
that black's got rid of the e pawn
uh that bishop on d5 just is is probably the
winning piece yeah uh must be the winning piece
you would need to put that e pawn back up by
e4 to kick it out you don't have an e pawn and
this is just horrible before it is and this i mean
this should level the match this one which is i
think we got time for probably just one more game
after this one so it's very close match and um
you know we were saying how well knee how's been
playing but hikers hikes been doing is to be doing
his stuff and this game's shown his kind of style
have just played uh of just playing this this way
where he's playing sensible moves and he's taking
his opportunities when he gets them he's defending
very well um it's going to be a very close
match very close match yes and i mean i i just
i'm thinking about the beginning of the match
where nihal was just seemingly winning in uh
the first he won the first two and then felt like
he was uh keeping it up and then game three when
hike held that draw and then in game four when
he turned a disadvantage into a win it does just
seem like hike has been playing better in some
critical moments in recent games and here is
no exception to that i mean look how long i'm
looking at time here that nihil spent a minute
and 49 seconds and played a4 which immediately
cost him uh his position so i think that hike is
improving and right now nihal is struggling he's
floundering quite a bit yeah i totally agree and
this is these are the points aren't they in the
match when you're playing the same opponent time
again you get these kind of runs and nihal had a
bit of a run to start and if he gets a little bit
despondent here a little bit annoyed it could
be now hikes time to take over the initiative
in the match situation he's going to level it
with this probably like say one more game after
this left in the five minute section um i mean
blacks are pawn up here the bishop on d5 is great
uh bishop on c3 is great it should be quite simply
winning as long as black doesn't uh as long as he
doesn't do something silly here and he went knight
f1 in knight c4 he would allow the capture on c4
with check but his idea clearly is to go knight to
e3 and if rook to d7 you still have knight e3 so
that's what yells hoping for i guess there
are some outside opportunities to hold this
game they just don't feel very likely because if
you can trade off maybe a pair of minor pieces
then you're only down one pawn and there are
certain end games right simon where you're
down upon but you still have very good chances
to hold especially in like rook in three versus
rook and four type of situations yeah yeah black
black's still squeezing away though knight e3
is a good place for the knight um you want to get
rid of that bishop that bishop's been so annoying
throughout the game if you can get rid of that
bishop i agree all of a sudden it's like okay
there's chances to to maybe hold some ending um
if you can get rid of that so i expect black will
if he can play just play something like bishop c6
trying to get a rook into d2 uh along those lines
if you guys you know then they have to come to c4
as a response and that's the square you've been
talking about all along the c4 square yeah okay so
now we get a pure ending so this is i don't know i
mean it it's still very good for black of course
it's good for black because black's got the space
advantage and now we're okay the rook's coming
to d2 that is a major rook he hasn't got the
the light square bishop but a rook on the seventh
rank should be should be doing the job bring the
king go rook b2 at the right moment or something
i guess yeah yeah the rook on b1 just can't move
because any time it does you'll rook b2 you
win the b3 pawn and if that's the situation
you're completely frozen like king e6 b5 just
bring that king in yeah i don't think exchanging
bishops helps here so and i i guess black's
gonna play e4 at the right moment so now rook b2
is is the critical move to play so bishop c5
he's you know he's creating some chances for
himself here take on a6 so can you go king f5 if
you want to put your king there but a g4 checkmate
if you if you forget with the opposite that
would be so funny if you saw any games g4
that's actually happened to me before not quite
like that but i checked my opponent at the british
championships and he castled and i i was really
confused because i put him in check he castled his
king i'm like how did i miss that move he's got
a really good position i just misplaced my queen
and then like 10 minutes later i realized actually
he couldn't castle because he was in check
so yeah it's like um bishop v7 is
the running rookie to meet though
look how quickly he saw rookie to an e4
yeah oh yeah he was expecting that one
so knee how's fighting he's fighting away
here yes stills chances but this f pawn look
at that he doesn't care about the g5 pawn
he's going to try and promote as quickly
as possible wise a wise choice there i mean
you can't stop you can't stop these pawns
no the bishop especially is so good covering this
one yeah and now can you just play f okay well i
guess ninja's gonna take no he can't do that even
oh nice rook to three check good inclusion there
by hiking he's just winning the game because
the rook is defended on d3 by this new queen
very nice game by hike and it's now three and a
half all wow three and a half all and this is most
likely the last game of the five minute segment
so can either player get an advantage before
then the speed heightens to three minutes each and
higher hike is back in it i mean he's really he's
a real tough competitor his hike um i actually
once saw in that position knight bd7 being played
um knight d6 check by 2200 player in round one
it was quite funny he's playing he's playing
uh richard right yeah richard reports
that's it he's an english player and he
played and this is his one chance to play
someone so strong and he played knight d7
that was the end of the game round one oh dear
embarrassing he was 22 i think he was 2250 the guy
who allowed this unbelievable that must be one of
the most heartbreaking experiences ever you have
such a great opportunity to play one of the
world's best that's a rare chance for a player
in that rating range and then you blunder check
me on the game and move four or five and then
yeah i haven't seen him play much chess after that
i have to say poor guy um interesting caracane we
haven't seen this kind of position before this is
this is quite a unique to the match so far because
it is going to get is it well it's already getting
quite sharp um the structure is is very unbalanced
but black's trying to get an attack going yeah
i wouldn't have expected nihal to play this from
the black side based on the repertoire we've seen
him use thus far on the match but now we're here
and i don't really mind black's position i think
that the king is quite safe on e8 you can choose
uh which way to castle but the problem will
be in the future these double left bones
yeah so he's got he's gone decided to go queen
side as well um white it's funny because white's
pawns haven't moved very far whatsoever you
know they're all sort of stuck on the second
rank but he's very solid and he's he's got
he's now development coming in with bishop g2
later on as robert pointed out the f pawn could be
a little bit weak um maybe there's knight d4 idea
at the right moment and then f4 on knight h4 and
f4 but it's it's it's fairly even so far this one
i think it's just harder for black to play
because look at his last bishop a3 e7 he
clearly wants to move his knight next and keep
the pawn defended but i don't really know what
black's plan is i see some moves i mean i can
move my knight out i can move my rook somewhere
but what's my actual plan whereas you just
mentioned a couple ones for what knight d4
followed by f4 knight h4 just to go after this
bishop for my bishop on g2 for one nine h4
and i i just feel like the immediate position
feels favorable for white yeah certainly i mean i
neha would like to go like knight b6 knight d5
knight b4 but you know this is going to take a
lot of moves and if white can get rid of the
bishop on f5 it probably just stops that plan
so that's maybe what he's trying to do but knight
b6 knight d5 the knight would certainly be better
on d5 but white's going to get his movement
first and he has he's got knight d4 at the moment
makes sense and bishop g6 the that's why i didn't
really love the nd4 compared to h4 is i thought
that you know taking the bishop would be part
of your plan because if that bishop stays here
too long there could be an issue on the queen
side which is where white's king resides yeah
yeah it's one of those positions where you'd like
to play you know like something takes c6 i mean uh
i'm just wondering if if there is if there was a
bishop take c6 fret there with knight takes coming
i mean that's why i think black's over defended
the bishop on on e7 here um so h4 played and yes
i i certainly think white's a little bit better
now he black's gone rather passive and he's got
this now he's played h5 that paul on h5 in an
ending could also be a little bit weak to sort
of you can go bishop free and try to take it at
the right time white doesn't have any pawns that
are weakness at all sure and i was going to add
that you can play g4 as spring free your h-pawn
and that's the problem with having double pawns
if there's a pawn on g7 anytime there's g4 i just
take and my g pawn will cover the h file but now
if i get g4 at the right time then comes h5 h6
and so on that pawn just translates yeah so i
suppose you could even go f3 and g4 with that
idea in mind then you know just one one simple way
to play so easier for white to play but nihal in
this game has got the time advantage he's still
quite solid um how's it going to deal with this
bishop e4 now i doesn't really want to play f5
this is again a very clever positional move i feel
from white because if black plays f5 okay he has
played it maybe i said maybe i'm saying it you
know maybe it's okay but bishop on g6 is now like
really bad it's really bad so white's tempted knee
how into doing this move to make that bishop bad
i wonder if the idea is that he'll play f4 next
because if bishop d3 i could put my knight on
c5 and just try to take off your bishop there
and so if i can play f4 i'm trying to shatter your
pawn structure on the king side for white so i'm
with you the bishop doesn't look very good but
perhaps it's just a temporary situation you know
yeah f4 looks like a good move to play that's at
the right point you know give a pawn up to cause
your opponent the pawn the structural problems in
the position um and maybe after bishop f3 you have
to play like f4 right because i don't know well
there's e5 as well actually e5 is quite nasty
i forgot about e5 e5 um and the knight where's
the knight gonna go so okay this is this is uh
these pawns could actually be quite active with
v5 if if black can play e5 and like some other
pawn move they're they're starting to they're
starting to cramp white's position a lot here
i actually quite like e5 right now because yeah uh
you know you're hitting this knight and then you
can even go e4 next and you can put your bishop
on f6 and hey the bishop on g6 doesn't look so
good but all your other pieces look much better
yes and white's very cramped you know take the
space when you can here as black e5 e4 i like it
go go positive in the position you should always
try to play the most positive moves if you can in
a position i i feel this is the right way to go
um but not if it weakens your position
that's that fine line of pushing
but not over extending uh is he gonna go e5 maybe
if it was after his runner wins he'd be playing
e5 immediately here because he'd be a lot more
confident and this is where you've lost the game
it's the last game you're a little bit more
cautious and you don't want to commit to
sort of playing such a move because you know you
are moving those pawns are they strong are they
weak and he's i guess he's trying to work that
out now and even though objectively that game
where he played uh you know g5 h5 g4 f5 all those
moves objectively those were good decisions he may
have bad memories of that and look he played
bishop f6 probably uh in part as you said he's
lost a couple games lately so he's just
let me play a little bit more solidly
yeah now again i i i guess he's preparing e5 he
wants to play e5 when the bishop's now in a better
square uh if he doesn't play e5 i mean white's
ideal situation here if he could like move that
knight to e5 somehow uh you know at the right
moment and just play against bishop on g6 but
as soon as you go knight f3 then e5 is is coming
so okay so queenie free here and there clearly
was some tactic i saw the bar jump up and down i
don't know what it was uh but there may be some
kind of knight takes c6 oh knight takes c6 was
was there something interesting anyway there yeah
yeah i just i just saw the bar jump and then go
back down so clearly there's a tactic there and
the only one i see was a knight takes a c6 type of
move so anyway we get our bishop c6 something like
that probably knight c6 the knight was hanging
let's just go for it yeah something like this oh
i made it blunder in the second move oh so it
doesn't like it anymore what the it had a huge
evaluate that's a problem with these like engines
on low depth because they trick us i didn't think
it worked but then i trusted the evaluation bar i
do not like commentating with the evaluation bar
i've said this many times same yeah but you know
it's not my call and it's tricky i should trust
myself more you darn evaluation bar over there
can't take you anywhere i totally agree i mean
i know a lot of people watching like the
evaluation bar because it gives them sort of
an idea of what's going on but there is a major
danger of and this is something that so many
players do and it really really annoys me that
they get so addicted to the evaluation bar they're
not even looking at the ball they're just looking
at the bar you know and they're sort of just
watching it go up and down they go oh yeah black's
just blundered white's so bad and they don't even
know what they're talking about you know they're
they're these sort of valuation bar junkies and
that's why it's nice just try to maybe you know
sometimes just don't look at it look at the board
make your own judgments i mean you're not gonna
gain anything by just uh concentrating on the
computer's evaluation uh it's a nice indication
at times though to see what's happening but yeah
yeah it gives you um ideas oh sorry it doesn't
give you ideas it gives you moves but not ideas
so especially in a position that right here
it's plus point two that i would say that we
would agree with that like we don't think
in those terms we're like okay white is
probably slightly better but you actually
have to come up with ideas yourself and
speaking of ideas a4 is his idea just play a5 and
a6 yes because the only way to stop a6 for black
would be to put your queen there in which case
the bishop would have just walked back to f1 so a6
now what's the claim here simon is it that the
space grab for white is beneficial because i'm
looking at this pawn a5 and i'm thinking end game
and that could be a weakness rather than a string
yeah sure i mean uh it's i mean you have got
this b6 square in some structures if you can
get your knight to c4 um you can try coming
into b6 or coming to b6 with your bishop
so white white is is aiming for this but i
don't think he's going to be able to get it in
knee how playing knight g4 and okay it's a very
weird position this one they're doing these little
you know it's gonna it feels like it's just
getting ready to jump into life very soon
and now their time's going down i can't predict
what the result will be here it's it's really
like just brewing brewing until the the crescendo
here yeah what is this rook takes e5 what a sack
because bishop had a queen a7 and neon's clock
he's only at 15 seconds right now this is this
is a great move i don't think nihal should
have got rid of his dark square bishop there
that was uh and this is this is very
dangerous okay oh bishop takes queen takes e5
love chess like this we're just getting a series
of trades simon he takes d5 yes keep that rook
on the open file but look at the bishop the
bishop on g6 is still a little bit funny right
i mean you can go f4 at the right time and you
probably have to but after like bishop f3 um
black's advantage is the e file so as long as he's
got that e file it probably does cancel everything
out but a time situation you know he's going
to go king d2 and rookie one right i mean i'll
rook f6 okay he's got this thing g4 now you might
have to try that move and to king you gotta go g4
i think is a great try especially in a bullet
scramble right now you gotta go g4 just so you
get the past h pawn in some positions just just go
for it easier plan to play you know he's done it
so you want it for a good response good response
definitely take with you the past using the rook
oh this is now this is now risky i think black if
he gets black gets the king to d5 rook behind the
past pawn we've seen this before surely black
is now pushing for the win oh yes and now you
can't play d5 for white because i just take and
actually a problem with the pawns on a5 and c5
you can't create a past pawn rook c3 check roxy
through check yeah oh this also works oh oh oh
very nice that was a very clever move now the pawn
queens so knee how oh that was that was an uff
i mean there were some crazy tactics there
to start with like hype played this brilliant
exchange stack but then nihal showed this great
understanding of the position because he could
have like tried to defend it but he gave back the
exchange immediately and then his end game skills
i mean heights and games still surround this
competition have been great but niihau you showed
some brilliance to you but this is certainly
the critical moment you know when i said it
was brewing robert i think i said it at the right
moment like bang it just happened here right so
i mean what a sequence of moves there where it
looked like uh hike was being the tricky one then
neil said hey i'm gonna calm myself down use most
of my remaining time and fend him off and simon
that's the end of the five plus one so that was
a very important win for nihal because he got off
such a blazing hot start he then was just
struggling through the middle portion of
the five plus one he wins the last game he
takes a one game lead into the shorter time
controls yeah definitely definitely and that's
that's a big lead you know that was that was a
really key game um that is the end of the five
minute section so next it's three minute plus
one second move um and it's hike's the one who's
gotta pull himself into gear in that section
he certainly does that was a time scramble we'll
see much more of those coming up but for now
we are going to take a break and when we return
we will have the three plus one portion of this
junior speeches championship brought match
brought to you by chess.com and chesky.com
and we return ready for the three plus one
portion of this junior speeches championship
match so far it's been a great one neil sarn is
out to a lead and simon he was the presumptive
champion if you will of this field when smarter
chess did the predictions you know crunched the
numbers it was neil sarnon at the end of the
day who was supposed to lift the title and well
hike martial rosen wasn't even supposed to be
here according to the numbers yeah i mean it's
i find this a smart sort of you know chess thing
that they're using here for the predictions is
it's very clever i mean i think it's got nearly
every prediction right it's certainly got the
majority of them right and um so nihal is is the
predictive winner i mean the thing is every close
every match is just so close um i mean i i mean at
the moment he's looking like still probably that's
a good opportunity for him to become winner he's
going that way sam sevion is supposed to be his
finalist in the final i don't know robert who's
going to do it is he going to do it well i guess
you know we have to not call smart chess out
necessarily but sam7 did lose to alexis saranac
so it's going to be jeffrey zhang versus serena in
the other semi-final awaiting the uh of course the
champion of this match and well we're they don't
even talk about us anymore they're starting their
games so they're in oh i was wondering if we're
gonna get a french much to my chagrin but i know
you like the french every now and then i like a
bit of french action yeah it's fun now and again
not all the time but occasionally and you can
see already they they've both picked up the pace
uh they had this position uh only in the last
game i think it was the one before the break
c5 played again um nihao didn't get much there
but he got some kind of advantage with this knight
g5 move was that right yes exactly right he
brought his knight g5 back to e4 and he blundered
when he made an eventual a4 move i find this is
one one thing that like blitz is very good for
in general i don't think blitz is great improving
your all-round chess it can be but for practicing
our openings you sort of uh especially against
the same opponent it can be very useful because
you can try to sort of improve on your play you
kind of know where you've gone wrong and you can
try out a different idea in the next game so
it's it's certainly got its advantage blitz
for doing this kind of thing knight e4 rook c1 is
he going to go for bishop b1 and queen c2 i doubt
it uh what's he going to do here i kind of want
it to happen because you've mentioned i'm also
looking at bishop c7 it doesn't work i don't think
but i'm trying to drag the queen onto a file where
i can get a discovery so not bishop c7 yet but
i'm looking at it i'm trying to make the tactics
happen bishop c7 is a really funky move isn't
it i mean it's their bishop c7 trying to use
those rooks for black can get a rook to c8 but i
yeah it doesn't seem to quite work here um i mean
black set up to me it might be a bit worse but it
is it's solid and it's quite hard to break down
thinking now nihal's thinking as well um you
can see that hike has really picked up the
pace he's only spent like five seconds getting
to this position so far um and he needs to pick
it up a little bit very close match at the
moment yeah what caught me off guard in this
game is though they repeated the line i moved 14
knight g5 and he all spent 18 seconds on that move
and you know he was expecting this he just played
it i don't know if he during the break looked with
an engine or with his coach being like hey can you
tell me where i make a mistake how can i improve
but he's spending way too much time with this oh
definitely maybe he hasn't adjusted as well as
i thought because this is the big thing when you
step from one time limit to the other you've gotta
you've gotta get into it quickly um obviously
if he loses this game by going very short of
time it's going to be bad but even in the five
minute section he was getting shorter time so this
he's going to have to pick up the pace certainly
during this uh one hour of the three minute blitz
he spent a minute and 24 seconds to play bishop b1
so maybe there was some tactical line that he was
looking at that i'm not giving enough credit
for but you cannot spend almost a minute and
a half on that kind of move no certainly not and
um i i i mean again white white's position it is
fine but so is blacks black doesn't really have
any weaknesses here black's developed the bishop
on b7 is a lovely piece that black has pointing
across the board towards g2 so this i mean this is
the kind of opening i don't think nihal should be
playing this particular line time and time again
personally because i i mean he lost that last game
in it and i don't think he's got anything here
and it's quite a tricky position to play for
white even black smooth is a lot more natural
at this time you want to play your moves
quickly um i just feel he shouldn't be playing
this opening again personally this variation
yeah suggestion i think that he will likely
mix it up in the future but right now it's haiku
spending a lot of time and i guess the reason why
is if the d6 square is now whites for the taking
because you brought the bishop back and if you
look at that there's tension with all of these
knights because if the knight on f6 took on e4
the d7 knight was hanging so it kisses rook on d8
which allows some kind of knight to d6 but i guess
he's claiming i'll just drop my bishop back please
think he's he's definitely got to think about your
bishop c7 now right i mean because he can't go
queen d8 anymore bishop c7 was like he's gonna
probably have to give his queen up for pieces was
he there or i don't know maybe the knight can come
to e7 i'm not sure that was just confusing me i
think he gets uh a lot of people too many pieces
right yeah he does two minor pieces and the rook
for the queen that's a lot that's a lot more too
much okay so we see the trades instead yeah
i don't think why there's anything here i i
know white certainly doesn't have anything i mean
the bishop on b7 is looking good as well i mean
h3 is just to move saying okay i've got to make a
move quickly let's do something but black has ways
to improve his position he can just exchange off
as well if he needs to but he's done his queen c6
this is what he did last time robert he did queen
c6 last time and uh i think nihal had to play e4
and e4 just lost the pawn and in this position
it's not as bad because e4 doesn't lose a pawn
but i mean you can go f3 but queen c6 seems like
a useful move for black anyway threatening mates
it's always nice to friend especially the quicker
time controls right yeah your opponent may be
caught off guard and he plays f3 but that weakens
e3 the good news compared to the other game is the
knight is still on c3 so in the other one the pawn
had gone to a4 and black's pawn was on b4 which is
much worse for nihal now his knight is at least
on a good square i'm looking at bishop takes a3 at
some point because the knight loses defender but
i guess uh he decides just hey let me just bring
my rook to e8 first that smarter choice i was
thinking of e5 as well some rookie eight you know
sacked the pawn but then bishop d4 like
unfortunately gets in the way of things but
he's played it this way um and it seems like black
is making more of the progress here personally
expanding in the center but white at least
has a grip on the e4 square here this is
this is holding it together for knee how at the
moment this square nice central concreted point
and then move e6 to e5 that could cause some
problems if the bishops get traded off so let's
say we have an exchange in e4 and then on b7 then
i have the d5 square like plant my rook and that's
what i'm looking at now like uk plays e4 i thought
even bishop e4 was possible there giving yourself
doubled isolated pawns but in return you get that
very important d5 square i guess he's doing it
this way he's getting himself d5 he's getting
d5 which is which is something i mean the pawn
structure is very symmetrical though and now black
has weighs in with like queen c4 etc but the time
the time situation is is something i mean black
black's sneaking his way into that position trying
his best for sure yeah the c2 c1 squares are under
black's control the queen on b3 is a nuisance
i think that bishop is a great move because bishop
g5 bishop f4 was the threat definitely and now
and also you know white can sort of if he
wants to okay bishop g5 anyway has been played
i think him white could just try to swap queens
if he wants to i mean it looks like black's
got the better of it but maybe there's
nothing here actually it's just it's
very even yeah queen c2 they may even throw in
rook d-check just to scare you hope you take my
rook actually this could go south for black all
of a sudden okay like isn't this rook coming to
d6 or the d7 in this g5 pawns under attack i think
it's very weird that he moved his queen backwards
there because he the black queen is so active why
is he retreated he's going to come into f4 but
this position this position is is obviously
a support up now yeah you've got this is not
so easy i think oh it's not easy at all you can
play a4 and just get this one or it takes gonna
take on b5 he'll have a pass pawn you go h4 kh3
that king can slide in the light squares as well
probably a draw probably should be a draw but
i mean look at the time blank's got to defend
this one a little bit right and oh watch out for
b okay don't play b7 too soon right you don't want
to rush that king h3 here oh he hasn't played it
because king h3 yeah bring that king up all right
so you can't take it because it would be h6 h6
h6 qg6 there's king g6 okay h6 look like a very
clever idea though didn't it i think it's winning
anyway but we don't go king of five i thought that
there might be some kind of uh checkmating net
against the white king but no now it's one okay
h7 and then h8 equals queen that's a very nice
end game play again i mean these guys very nice
play um that was i mean that went from a position
where it's completely equal to to uh black playing
a couple of negative moves queen when the big one
there was black retreating his queen out of that
danger zone and when you got such an active piece
going backwards i think it was because uh you know
he wanted to avoid a draw there maybe maybe he
wanted to avoid some perpetual queen c2 rook d2
but you know if the draw is the best move
to play you've got to play it because
queen c2 i think would have led to a draw um with
best play but going passive here certainly a big
mistake no turn it around so quickly because now
white's controlling the open file black is the
one with the weak pawn and a very nice conversion
by knee holland as we get to the current position
nihal up two points he's on the black side of
this one uh just standard opening fair at this
point and a four typical move trying to chisel
open the queen side but that's why you play a6
if white plays a5 you just push through to b5 yes
um more of a sort of london system kind of set up
here now that we're seeing this is a standard
really london setup pawn structure with black
playing quite actively in the center maybe with e5
coming on in a position at the right moment here
that's the goal which is why in part the bishop
slides back to h2 so e5 doesn't come with kind of
full effect yeah black making the simple exchanges
um is he going to go for e5 he is going for e5
so anyhow not worried about that one the problem
with playing e5 for black is after there's a mass
exchange on e5 yeah the d5 pawns weak right so
you know you've got your bishop the dark square
bishop is white outside of the pawn structure
a lot of these positions look like a slav
but the bishop on h2 is a really good
piece in the slav it's often on c1
where it's a really terrible piece and that's why
it's not easy for black to break with e5 it might
weaken black's position rather than anything
else uh it's solid though if black does nothing
what's white doing does white have to
play b4 to to make progress well okay
he can do that but again you could weaken
yourself from the c file by doing that one
exactly and that's why the rook came to c8
preemptively queen comes to b3 black can play
c4 at some moment but i would not do that you know
releasing the tension feels like a bad thing for
black to do just yet d takes c5 you cannot take
with the pawn on c5 because you lose the bishop
on b7 so after dc5 you'd have to take with a
piece at the very least you get in you're no
longer symmetrical pawn structure you can't take
with the knight because the b6 pawn is hanging so
i would consider d65 if i'm trying to play for
a win and he does that he's played it yeah yeah
and he's going for this the queen takes is pretty
much force because that weakness on b6 um still
a solid structure this is again a little bit of
shadow boxing really going on here um both sides
not making major progress in the position
knight d4 black you could even say has a
bit of a better structure with more central
pawns and a bit more space to maneuver but
at the moment nothing serious has happened to
either size position yes because the base pawns
are all safe and sound right the b2 pawn hard to
get to f2 g2 all safe and you're not attacking
me so you know where to make pro i don't know
if i like that decision that's a very committal
decision taking that you know giving up the
bishop pair but now allowing black potential
to attack on well i'd say on the b8 h2 diagonal i
mean something like bishop bishop could drop him
back there i i why give up the bishop like that
when there's no need to was he really scared of
that knight so much it seemed he seemed robert
i agree i yeah not offended he didn't want the
knight to jump to c4 i gather but this bishop
on e5 is such a great piece and honestly simon i
like your idea of just swinging the bishop back
to well now it didn't make sense as much to go
to b8 because the palm is on f4 but going for
that kind of plan looks good e5 certainly still
a possibility for black put my rook on e8 play e5
go after this e3 pawn i love black's position here
yeah i mean white's trying to rely on this knight
on d4 to save him because that knight on d4 you
can only get rid of it by exchanging the bishop
for it now so this is like his one big thing and
it doesn't look so bad for white here i mean
i've had these kind of positions in the dutch
this this now resembles some kind of stonewall
dutch or something like this where you know
it's not terrible because e5 white's positioned
himself to get that counter play on the f file um
why why this king g8 i don't understand king g8
it seems peculiar to me and rook a8 why oh rook
defends the pawn okay i see that one so yeah okay
i had the same reaction about king g8 i was like
well what does that help i guess he wants to
give himself some space on g7 with the bishop
yeah and he's gonna play f5 i think he i think
he's gonna try to stop maybe any break with e4 if
he can but i like this g4 move this is just like
right he's played it straight away he's he's doing
this positive move on on the king side it might
be a terrible move but i still like it you know
it's sort of a it's a move that i'd have to play
myself just to just to push over there um can
you can you try to play e4 or f5 for white
again very careful about doing those moves
but i'm looking at f5 square for black as well
like can black play f5 but there's always danger
of a queen g2 h4 h5 and you're creating some
weaknesses on that side of the board so i
actually don't see how black gets like active here
the bishop on b7 we know how that bishop can get
stuck behind his pawn on d5 and then knight on
d4 is blockading it so all things considered
maybe white's position is turning around the
other very risky plan is to try f6 and e5
because that is one way you can get rid of that
knight okay he hasn't gone for this and i assume
that this this was not the right way for black
to play because you've given white the open file
and it i mean if he wanted to go e5 robert
he should have done it earlier surely
when white wasn't as well positioned white has
now got pressure and as you're pointing out
he can i don't know if you can take there
immediately but queen f2 very natural move
could you take that i don't know probably not
it's hard to evaluate it especially with such
a little time in your clock you think the
two rooks are better than the queen and
especially the e3 pawn being so weak so i just
like black's position now because you have at
least a planet bishop h6 at any moment can swing
here hitting e3 he plays it why not well that's
a good move yeah i missed that one oh i missed
e4 though okay what's happening here okay f7
f7 is coming in and the bishop's trying it's
really heating up now yeah nihal again is
behind on the clock but he plays so well with
his shorter time so well okay rook takes f7 and
oh what is happening here so rook back to e7 i
guess but this certainly looked good for white
queen bishop e3 watch out for that
yeah bishop three is a nasty one
can i just like slide my king up you
can't move bishop e3 because i broke
f8 check your bishop is needed to defend
the square oh my gosh he plays king tuned
good good move well well well found there robert
the knight on d4 is very strong if you can keep
it there right very strong you've got bishop
c2 as well you've got i mean the bishop a8
white white is probably pushing but look at the
time keep an eye on the clock here it's 15 seconds
versus six seconds he's going i think white's
trying to go for it yeah queen h4 the bishop's
hat's gone back and he's okay he's he's i would
say i was about to say you very good sack yeah
practically speaking just just play it he should
have thrown a queen e4 check before taking on d4 i
think because he could take on d4 with the bishop
but now his king's on h8 not the best square for
the king but allows d4 once that queen moves out
the way there's gonna be d4 with bishop d1 to go
to f3 okay so that's that's the way to combat
that one but black's grabbing a lot of pawns
he's got two seconds well through 22 check but
there's rook f2 keep an eye on the clock though
you have to you have to barely gets the move off
i'm just looking at knee how's clock and it's it's
freaking me out i mean it's okay good move
for five queen do you want this oh my gosh
it looks so rocky for blackness sorry
rocky's just grabbed the pawn here
so queen g1 check keep giving that king
checks queen h1 gain some time okay
very important queen g2 queen h2 to
keep on h5 maybe i guess and then uh
okay queen a1 check keep it going just check
forever i would have blundered a queen by now
look dear to me if you allow it can you avoid
the check so king g4 maybe you can avoid to check
somebody great move yeah now queen g5 and h5 is
falling and watch out for eight made in h7 though
well i just follow a check so that doesn't help
who's even better here i don't even know better
this is what i'm trying to work out i think that
white is better because the clock yeah yeah he's
keeping the pressure on right and he just he's
got a checkmate for it it's nice to have that fret
okay queen f to the king to
be through three queen g8
oh my gosh and everything's under control
oh no he's just watching this oh he just
checked and rooked in that part of that week
couldn't you be three equivalent three queen
how did he find out so quickly
oh that was insane oh my gosh oh
and i just like grabs his head in
frustration wow how do you hold that
i i have to say i'm sorry i'm so impressed how
nihal just saw that immediately and you robert
but i mean that was just like he was playing with
one two seconds he was given one opportunity back
he took it immediately in under a second that was
incredible he's been pushed back pushed back he's
defending trying to get a draw and as soon as
he sees an opportunity he takes it immediately
i mean okay i mean queen b3 maybe not so hard
to see but when you've got one second all the
time and stuff he's he plays it so quick
and bishop g5 incredible i mean that was
so impressive anyhow brilliant brilliant play
from him absolutely brilliant i mean i i you
said it you would have been checkmated like eight
times over i would have been checkmated 15 times
over or lost on the clock he didn't neither he was
giving all the checks and then still finding like
these little moves like your bishop to f8 at
the right moment and just fending off hike and
you this is danger territory because of tilt
right you you're so upset with yourself you're
winning that game at some point and now you're
like i'm down three how do i come back yeah
no i mean the the bullet section is going
to be incredible as we've seen this section
is incredible already but it's time for hike to
start he's got to hike up his game a little bit
was terrible don't make me do that again please
let me guess you commentated with daniel recently
and now he's the guy how could you tell he
he's the he is the grand master of puns right
oh they're so bad they're so bad they are so
bad they're so bad they're good right so okay
maybe just bad maybe just bad let's just
do that oh man well b4 not possible because
bishop takes b4 is a free pawn the rook on
a1 is hanging so king e2 i guess and then
bishop a6 okay because i mean d2 i guess
exchange of queens is a solid way to play maybe
if they those guys come off you might have some
c file action hence why black's kept them on um
normal-ish position but black black's nicely
developed he's got that extra tempo right with
the development and the threat here positionally
is for black i guess to play bishop takes bishop
you don't really want to take with your f
pawn i mean it's not the end of the world but
it's it's not really ideal either well that means
that bishop takes d6 might be forced and he does
that just because of what you were saying and
bishop d2 so white has retreated thus far and
black is in perfect position to play queen g6
where a to c8 and i'm not trying to claim that
black is better here but he's certainly no worse
this is also a nice idea isn't it put the knight
on e4 at some stage uh nice light squares for
the white pieces uh i think he he needs to get
a result here hike must get a result otherwise
he's just slipping too far behind if he goes
behind this he's going four games behind he
can come back but you know the rot the rot is
getting worse and worse every every little every
little time and it's funny this match because
it reminds me a lot of the part that the match
that um height got through on um against was it
uh parham yeah it was against parham and in that
game it was you know it was right at the critical
moments it was always hike who was getting better
or the better sort of edge of it in the critical
moments in this match it's knee how and niihau
i think's been playing a bit bad positional
chess as well but like that last game critical
moment he found the move with seconds to spare
and is that just killer instinct which is which is
really strong in the house game yeah the ability
to turn defense into offense and the snap of
your fingers is something that honestly most
people don't have yeah yeah i know it's it's
phenomenal fairly solid here though right i
mean this this this is this is even this must be
but it doesn't mean it's a draw have they had any
draws yet i'm not sure if there's i'm not sure oh
that has because it's half a point on the board
have they had just one draw or three draws i don't
really remember too many draw i think just one
maybe just one yeah yeah that that half a
point gives it away a little bit i should
probably probably look at the scores before i ask
such questions but it's um there hasn't been many
and even though this is equal just because it's
an equal position does not mean it's going to
be a draw i mean this is something well worth
remembering again the computer addicts they say
the position is 0.00 and they think oh that's
an easy draw but then no it doesn't mean it's
an easy draw ever well sometimes king versus
king king versus king maybe you know but yeah
yeah we'll we'll give that one a draw
but here bishop f3 e4 for example
has black overextended the pawn structure oh
and is this bishop on b7 becoming a bad piece
that does happen in plenty of end games so you
have to think about the quality of the pieces
so i would play bishop f3 and i guess there's
knight e4 potentially he such as trades and then
bishop three okay this is i mean it's pretty level
pretty level um again black black pushing with h5
is not so stupid um the one thing about
having that pawn there is a strength is
it weakness that black's got on the e4 square
it does cramp white's king's side a little bit
a normal idea then would be to push the h-pawn
but there's not enough pieces on the board really
to cause trouble to the white king i'd say and
um that stops knight before good move a5 yeah
you'd probably need a bishop on d6 if to make you
know justify any kind of king side yeah i'm still
with you though simon i actually know that i'm
looking i do think black's position is better with
the queens in the board especially so he plays
h6 is he trying to go g5 and he could have gone
g5 without h6 he's playing very safely isn't he i
mean like probably just a good waiting move i mean
it's a bit more space for black to maneuver in but
white is super solid and black's pawns whoa okay
that's interesting look at that it's sacrificing
a pawn i was going to suggest that move but i was
like yeah it's not worth it because you're giving
up a pawn but you're freeing up your knight giving
yourself the b5 the f5 square this could be
a really smart sacrifice of a pawn for the
positional edge very clever actually very clever
idea i mean giving that pawn up and suddenly
white's pieces have got these good squares black's
d pawn doesn't look great at the moment but
pawn is also porn let's not forget if the queen's
come off the board then that pawn could be the
telling factor right so white not really proving
the compensation after that for the pawn i'd say
though uh h5 now played in the time situation neat
but niihau with little time he's been phenomenal
so far um i mean that was i mean really clever
sacrifice even if it hasn't worked out well
yeah and he actually didn't even look
at the clocks and now that i am it's
bishop h5 and then five no there's queen e5 but
i'm looking at some kind of just sacrificed make
use of this queen on the diagonal okay queen
c there's reasonable but something e5 maybe
put the queen there put the knight there i'm not
sure still it's still compensation still some
compensation eight seconds left for nihal that's
the worst part for him so he should just instead
of trying to play for a win at this point just
make normal moves 95 is missed by knight b5 so
you have to be careful that's why the queen can
be e5 okay going to the a7 square that's the hope
but i think needs to try and win this
one yeah and he's if you can get the
queens off he'll be very happy because then
the extra pull might help at some point um
isn't trying to get a knight c4 to work but then
pin the bishop at the end but no it's not i don't
really like f6 so much it makes the king feel
weaker yeah and that could tell if the the white
queen comes around the back here but it's on the
clock i mean like i'm just looking at the clock
again this is like when it gets this situation
i mean i can't even commentate because i'm just
looking at the clock and by the time i've got
something to say it's ten moves are gone you know
right and i mean this is critical because b5 at
some point could be a good move to take oh nate
check the kingdom coming in okay there's bishop
b5 check as well should be five don't play king d8
d6 oh my gosh bishop 88 or something knight to
b5 was a threat oh he's got in he's got him yeah
you think cringy go over there for me how the
queen has got in he's taking things man this guy
nina is just killing it when he's got no time look
at the time he's killing it oh knight c6 check is
possible at some point don't take on b4 okay now
you can't design a take the queen a1 quenty one
go all the way back nice move oh my gosh bishop
me too go bishop me to bishop h5 it's almost
made what is happening here that's already oh
it's just insane it's going backwards forward
oh no so queen day you only goes queen you just
take it and take on b6 you have many pawns for
the sacrifice many queens by the looks of it as
well it's going to be a draw queen you want queen
h4 back and forth are you going to take the draw
is he going to try to win i reckon he might try to
win this i mean so i don't know how no he can't
try to win this can he oh he does he is going
to try to win this i mean very confident player
and i and as you said i think he needs to get
a result of this i mean a win out of this really
but he can't he is closer to a loss than anyone oh
okay yeah you're right he has to take the draw
okay oh my gosh let's pull up this uh on the
analysis board really quickly because there was
that moment where it went from winning for white
to winning for black and like just the move
because where was that it was all the way down
here somewhere e3 allowed bishop d3 check and it's
mate the king has nowhere to go here here boop
that's mate and instead he went bishop to f3 and
then after queen f2 you see that the evaluation is
in black's favor because he could have just taken
his knight instead of playing e2 yeah but i mean
when you've got so so little time i mean it's
it's really hard to play at the level they're
playing at you're gonna make blunders it's totally
impossible but bishop d3 it's always good to look
for the checks you know that's one thing if i see
a check i'm that passo will play it in these kind
of positions you never know it might be mate and
that was very close it's checkmate it actually is
just check me it was yeah it would be exactly
i'd like that check the check oh my gosh but
it is easy for i always say it's easy for me to
shout moves and occasionally be right than to be
in the heat of the moment where the responsibility
of that move is on your shoulder so what
is this by the way and this is not a very
knee-haul-like position what's he done here
i mean you know the pawns placement like that i
mean this is this is like this just looks a bit
i mean he's going for that kind of g5 attack we
saw earlier but he's doing it in a very ugly way
here i mean it might not be so bad the knight
coming to f4 it looks ugly it looks wrong it
just looks wrong to me i mean too many light
square holes there surely and i guess you know
this knight needs to get to e3 wait so can you
take on d4 i was wondering yeah why not take the
pawn take it is he going to try to go f4 and he's
going somebody will tactic we can't i don't know
i would steal that pawn for sure yeah yeah grab
the pool ask questions later take a pawn now
ask questions later um but do you think that hike
is just super frustrated by that last game um
i think he's been a bit frustrated at times i
mean he's still keeping his call i think very
well i mean i when i've seen hike in other you
know competitions and earlier on this competition
he seems one of the coolest players as in he
really doesn't get affected he keeps his call but
niihau has rocked him a bit and it might be it
might be showing now yeah i'm just looking at
the uh the cameras of both players we also have
a fun photo of both players throwback photos
this is the matchup you see today a young nihal
versus a young hike martial ocean and of course
that's not what they look like today but it's a
nice little throwback to their even younger youth
yes these guys started they started very young
definitely their chess career when did you start
playing robert when i was about six years
old okay uh so pretty young myself but not
the three-year-old standard that people
started today i guess what about you
about the same about six years old as well the
standard i think for for most sort of uh most
a lot of players now seem to get six for some
reason i don't know why but i feel like i've
heard stories of people like yeah i learned chess
when i was three i was like when i was three i
didn't know how to do anything except bothering
my parents for food i know yeah breastfeed
on earth is going on here either i mean like
it's it looks like black has a look okay black
i mean black's still that pawn up is there any
compensation here i like the still the light
square control and that hasn't changed maybe some
kind of knight e4 where's that queen going what
knight b4 other direction trying to come into
d5 which has a very nice square for tonight
i mean it is i mean the white king is is safer
than the black king um if things do open up a bit
more the black king it's a little bit there's some
weakened squares on the e file like we're seeing
that knight come to d5 right but can i take on c3
and sacrifice my queen like take on c3 knight d5
i take my opinion let's see it let's see i
want to see that queen going i'm going i'm
going full pac-man you know i just like give up
my queen and then take yours with check and then
take this knight at the end and i have two minor
pieces and a rook for the queen that's too much
yeah the bishop on bishop on a7 is a really
really nice piece wait this is all happening
oh wow okay oh gosh always happened this
has happened this is just terrible news for
for hike yeah this is bad news i mean
black's piece has controlled everything now
yeah very weird game this is this has to be said
this probably one of the one of the worst games
that hikes played maybe it is affecting a little
bit these uh these positions he's not converting
this is not what he was looking for from this
opening and i mean the way that nihal played
it like i said was very unnihal like with all
these holes in his position but i think that
went too quick he was like i need to win this
game i have a better position and i think he
lost some objectivity yeah this is just too
many extra pieces it should be yeah knight e4
is very nasty you can even push the h4 with black
as well i love that you think about that and it's
actually a very good move but i would never
push h5 and you're like you could just go h5
h4 go for it i'm just thinking the bishop on g3
oh he's got rid of it anyway i mean it's it's
27 and a half minutes more
or less for this portion
and when you're down pointed a match sometimes
you just have to resign and play the next game
right there's still plenty of time left in this
match but there is i don't know if i'm if i'm hike
i guess i still play this game out there
are some chances but i would also consider
resigning no i'm with you actually robert
there there is that game play element
you want to play until the end but he's going to
be four points down at the end of this game and
he's got to give himself as much time as he can
resigning is probably one of the best moves you
can do as black here i mean especially now i mean
this is this is just absolute onslaught now um
he's probably going to get perpetual check now
it's like oh yeah yeah i mean there's one check
on d7 this rook can slide back so i would even
consider rookie one going against this king
it's a rookie seven for sure and rookie one
i mean okay he's touching it a little bit
is he gonna keen g6 and h5 push his h1
okay so is there a mate it feels like
there has to be some kind of made down
on the first rank oh he's keeping
he's keeping total control bishop e3
total control d5 d4 he is all day only hope
white has is to get the queen to g6 if white can
somehow get his queen to g6 can he get stale
mate is there a stalemate somehow you know
at some point this is the other hope oh
rook h1 king g4 okay it's not checking yeah
yeah yeah yeah so rook h1 king g4 you give up your
queen it's stalemate like queen d4 oh ricketts for
a check ricketts where check was there oh oh my
gosh rook h4g takes rook f4 oh very nice very
nicely spotted there very nice yeah so instead
the queen remains on the board here oh gosh that's
this is some of those opportunities where i've
just seen enough of these matches to just go for
it i figure out wait how do i win your queen to
simplify the position and it's very very nicely
spotted there okay he's still winning rookie four
check g4 can be played after that if you want
this is just amazing hasn't finished him off
i mean hike's been very very resilient here
but the thing is if he ends
up losing this game anyway
he's he's definitely made the wrong decision
right because he's wasted even more time
yeah this is uh actually kind of annoying if
you're black right you're like i'm winning this
game but where's the win i know now he has to push
the d pawn which should be enough but you still
okay that's easy he's got everything covered
now everything is covered he's covering g6 he's
covering his bishop he just pushes the deep on
this yeah that's it yeah yeah that was uh i think
i should have it's always easy in hindsight to
say oh we should have resigned that four minutes
before but um he probably should have oh gosh
um yeah so i guess i have to pull this on the
screen because i see my producer wanting me to
this is me at six i don't know if you know that
i was six years old in this photo happens to be
in the u.s championship but i was six for sure
you matured very quickly
yeah i came out of the womb with a
beard simon bit like me robert yeah so
thank you to bic for uh pulling up that pick
always fun to you know have some jokes but
what is not a joke has been nihal sauron's play
and for hike marty rose in some if you were his
coach if you were training him or just trying to
give him words of encouragement at this point what
do you say well i mean it's been tough because
nihal's just been so strong i mean knee how
is keeping he's playing a lot of different kind
of positions now as well he's spotting tactics
and so if i was hike's trainer i'd be like okay
well look you know you're still playing good chess
as he is he's playing good i think you need to
change the tempo a little bit um you're running
out of time in the match so if you go at this pace
you're probably gonna you know i'm not going to
say this that you're going to lose the segment
but i say right go a bit more aggressive try try
switching it up a little bit just try try now not
the openings you're playing at the moment they're
not really working try something else you must
have another opening in your arsenal give it a go
so i think that'd be my advice just go a little
bit more aggressive you're playing good chess
the score doesn't really affect how well how
how well you're playing just go more aggressive
i mean it must be you know you've got to change
something if if you're in a bad score right
yeah he he simply must because this is the type
of position where white objectively is better and
practically just too easy to play so he puts his
bishop on d5 and you can bring your knight into
d6 if you'd like you can just play e4 to kick this
bishop out how how are you going to get results to
fix the situation you're down four points in
the match at a certain point a draw equals a
loss yeah totally because you're just wasting
time and uh you know if you if you don't i mean
the thing with these players is we're seeing
we're seeing hype playing pretty much the same
opening time and time again which obviously has a
lot of faith in or getting similar positions but
these players have more than one opening nowadays
they must have looked at other openings so
why not try something else try your other opening
out give something else a go because at one point
he was getting more favorable positions hiked
than he's really getting so just try something
different you have to you have to mix it up uh in
the match situation at this moment it's getting to
your last opportunity and what was interesting
when jeffrey zhang played against arjun arigasy
he was saying jeffrey said that i had played uh d4
in one time segment e4 and another so he actually
had a very concerted plan of i'm going to switch
my first move depending on how much time we begin
with and here we've seen a lot of the similar
openings and in this particular game simon has
a knight on d4 this is a knight and e5 bishop b2
bishop c so all of white's pieces are harmonious
here and black just doesn't have the type of
counter play you need to play for not even
just an advantage but just you're having a hard
time stopping white's clear progress yeah i mean
like you say it's a very good setup for white
because you've blunted that bishop on b7 with
f3 and e4 but it's the white knights and the
white bishop on b2 which could cause problems and
um this is not what you want you don't want
this position so i i would say he must change
his opening for the next game when he's black um
okay now queen queen f2 looks sensible but yeah
this queen can go to g3 or to h4 depending on how
black reacts here queen v8 is also sensible right
get trying to get rid of that nightmare i mean
okay black's position is not it's not disastrous
he hasn't got that many weaknesses in in the
structure but he he's not he's got to win these
positions and he's not unbalancing the structure
enough i'd say symmetrical structures maybe try
to go for more unsymmetrical structures when you
have to win win the game right you get more losing
chances but you get more winning chances and
i'm looking at the uh the time by the way and uh
nihal only has 48 seconds and his position doesn't
look that great and also what's annoying is oh oh
he's falling for a trick he's fallen for tricks
so blacks play after all this criticizing he his
plays now is is now turning around so of course
this was a heist plan from the very beginning
he knew exactly what he was doing a master plan
here no his position was not that good but nihal
he has shown this tendency today simon where
he's wait queen takes e5 three pieces yeah oops
he shook his head he was like wait i didn't see
my nose well probably should play on yeah i mean
there's no point residing here because the time
situation your three games are if you're going
for pure gaming thing but i mean okay maybe it's
only a gain of 30 seconds in the match he wants
to get into the next one that was a bad game from
nihal that's his that was his worst game so far
going from a position where he's better really
throwing it away and he's now playing a very
sharp opening um his three points up this
is a very sharp and tactical variation
is it wise to play is it is it wise to suddenly go
so sharp when you're when you're leading the match
oh hike is probably thrilled because this gives
him an opportunity to avoid just basic symmetry
and this variation is quite complicated for
example queen takes c4 is check and it looks like
it wins your piece by taking on f6 but the problem
is i think i can go 92 whichever move i'm not sure
the theory but the point is that once you take on
f6 i have rook c1 and i win your bishop on c8 so
i think it is kg1 but anyway the point is rook c1
and the bishop is hanging so you can't just take
on f6 so instead we see all this uh other theory
where there's a king on e7 simon i think that
you're right nehal probably should play something
a little more tame but hike is happy to be here
yeah i mean the this is the kind of opening you
know if you're trying to learn this at home by the
way a word of warning you know you can learn these
kind of things but you better make sure you have
a good memory really i mean i don't really like
nowadays relying on my memory to play a game of
chess because if you play one bad move you lose
there's other ways of playing it it is quite a
sharp position even though now it's died down a
little bit just because the black king is in the
middle of the board and when you're leading
the match okay i mean he's very confident of
playing every sort of style of playing knee
how as he's shown before so it might not be
a bad decision but it's a different kind of way of
playing that what he's done so far yeah and i mean
the bay issue for black is your king will never
find true shelter if you trade the queens off
well then your king is great it's in the center
but white is not trained the queens both because
of the match situation and what's going on on
the board and the queen on d3 bishop c4 rook c1
all these pieces even the knight on b3 they're
all working together quite well black's rook a8
bishop c8 not in the game quite yet so black is
up a pawn but is delayed in development yes i
and again it might be all right for black this
position but it's practically speaking practically
speaking it's very hard for black to play it's
quite easy for white to play white can just keep
the pressure on black's position but if you're
kings in this structure you make one mistake
you lose so it's sort of practically speaking
harder for black um pointing out some good ideas
there robert white seems it seems to be a good
idea to try and get the rook to d1 certainly
in such a structure although i do wonder now
that i made this suggestion if there's like a
queen h2 that i have to keep an eye on because
26 it defends off the diagonal from any checks
but it also can give that queen the h2 square
which could be quite annoying yes i mean if nihal
can get bishop d7 as well and just get his rook
somewhere he's improving his position so this is
preparing to meet bishop d7 with knight c5 and so
he's he's trying to stop this developing move and
will he what he's got to play knight c5 now on
the option so he gives up the b7 pawn because
there's queen gotta be careful queen a3 something
queen a freeze okay so he's getting the queens off
he's just saying right i don't want to defend this
position have the pawn back get the queens off
this is my safest way this is actually very
clever black was a pawn up when you're defending
if you can just give your pawn back to liquidate
the position so you're safe it's often the best
technique in the position and and i think it's
worked seems to be working okay here and there's
no choice for hike because he would like to keep
the queens on the board and go after the q87 but
queen d3 is the only way to protect the bishop
but after queen e3 is knight e5 hitting the queen
protecting the bishop threatening your bishop one
b5 threatening your rook on c1 i think you can
get the point there's too many pieces under
attack and black's just completely winning
yes so okay well he's the queens are coming
off but maybe black has some other options now
possibly like probably not actually yeah i think
the queen takes e4 but i'm worried about your
queen a3 idea at some point the king is not very
good in the center but maybe i can i don't know
can i get away with it i've got queen c5 i can try
it out quincy five is crushing yeah i was looking
at queen a3 but not the better and more forward
option okay okay so more exchanges being made here
can anyone claim an advantage in this
position well you did say earlier on
the one good thing about black's position is his
king right and uh if the queen's come off black
has the king in the middle of the board and he
does have the king in the middle of the board so
with that b pawn now being very weak it's uh
bishop d how did you just stop bishop d7 next move
is it maybe black's just winning this you still
play well this is the wrong pawn right the corner
does not match the bishop right so you
look at the a1 square and the bishop on d7
they don't match if white can trade all of the
king side pawns then the game will be a draw even
without this knight and a5 so that's how i think
about these positions that's one big if though
there's a lot of pawns to get off yeah it's gotta
but you know it it should be a technical windows
because the other thing you've got to remember
about a knight a knight is the worst piece for
defending uh a pawn on the side of the board an a
or an h pawn because it can't jump off the board
to get to the other side you know you can
only stay sort of half on the side of it
it's better defending a pawn in the middle
of the ball because it can use both sides to
stop that pawn from coming forwards and
i i hope you like my sign language there
the knight jumping around there i thought it
was excellent simon and you know you're if this
bishop could get to d5 the game would just be
over because the knight is trapped and that's
your whole point the knight in the side of the
board has just huge limitations yeah so i mean
you can try going f5 for that reason then you
know if you want to i mean position yeah he's
played it honestly he takes can you play bishop
d5 very i mean it okay it's he's gone for the more
safer approach now knight now bishop d5 surely
this is total domination now total domination
net strategy game over that's really nice
i mean that bishop dominating that night
is that pattern and one of those patterns in
chess which as soon as you see it as soon as you
remember it your game will improve instantly um as
is the case here yeah and i always say this when i
commentate a pawn three squares away from a knight
dominates it a bishop three squares away for night
just i mean takes all of its squares away and
here we go you'll see yeah just king b5 or
you're pushing the part first you go a3 use that
positive decoy and bring his king to the king side
he's just he got this one yeah the outside past
pawn it is is nearly always winning the extra
outside pass pawn in the king and pawn ending
i think you can see now hayek's body language
dropped down a little bit as well he hasn't got
the same energy had at the start of the match
understandably knee how now mixing up the
opening even more here with e3 okay we're
backing back into normal positions time they got
12 minutes left robert does hike have any chance
i think he needs with these final 12 minutes he
needs to get a couple victories to end the time
until otherwise nihal's bulletproofs will be
seen but before we see anything else i have to
bring our attention to a younger simon williams
how old were you here don't tell anybody yet i
want to guess i want to guess okay how old was i
here um um you know what i i i can guess how old
i was there i had a non-bearded sign with him so
i'm 40 years old now and uh i can yeah i mean wow
the innocent look at my face were you like 17
there younger i think i might be like about
i don't know i i don't even know how old it was
that's the problem i had no idea i'm guessing
i was probably 17 or 18 yeah i think i was well
we'll have to get confirmation of that i have no
idea where our producer pulled that photo from no
i know i'd like to know how old i was i don't know
the years have been rough i personally like
the beer i think it's a great look for you
so uh you babyface simon from back in the day
has nothing on you know bearded babies debated
and all simon we did say we didn't think that
hike should play this again he is playing
this line once more and nihal shouldn't be
too fearful of what's to come in this game
yeah i mean it's it's he did win that game
when we said he should be doing it but
the positions he's getting on you know how
like we say 10 minutes left they just don't
seem unbalanced enough the one good
thing about this opening i suppose
black does keep all the pieces on the board for a
long time and that keeps a lot more tension than
other openings where maybe they get exchanged
off quickly it's just the pawn structure i i
i don't really think is a good way to go for a
win yeah and you know you look at the pieces and
which pieces are better the rooks are connected
for white and black's work on f8 not in the game
just yet and often white tries to take advantage
of that fact you can play b4 i wouldn't do that
because it gives the a4 square but you can play b4
to kick this knight on c5 whereas the knight of d4
is stable where it is this knight can jump into
e5 quite easily the bishop on b1 stairs at the
king side as is the fisherman b2 so i just feel
like many of white's pieces are better placed
than blacks and that's why it should be a
slight advantage yeah nicely pointed out though
um not easy to use that advantage to to create
something as we've seen but he's put his knights
in the same same structure as we saw in the last
game this knight on e5 knight on on d4 but black
playing quite solidly in the position as well
now he has managed to connect the rook so
it's it's probably okay for black i thought that
he could have gone knight to g4 instead of knight
d4 to f3 like if we just go back and move knight
to g4 like i want to start trading stuff to get
after your king with my pieces and i don't think
it really should work but the threat is often
stronger than the execution yeah it looks scary
that one get rid of the one defender the knight
on f6 and just go for the kill their style
of chess it is quite it's quite i suppose um
patient um throughout the match they've both been
showing a great deal of like you know preparing
preparation not rushing into any king side attack
we haven't seen really any outrageous attacks
against eva king they you know it happens
much later on the game they've been building
maneuvering it's very mature you know you say
that younger players in the past when you know
certainly they were supposed to be more tactical
and not as mature but these two have shown a great
deal of maturity uh in their play they certainly
are they're showing restraint which is very
difficult uh for a lot of younger players not just
younger players i mean i feel the same way yeah
yeah i feel like it's either one or the other you
show too much restraint and really you're hesitant
and you're not actually striking when the moment's
right or you're just going full steam ahead trying
to sacrifice even when the position doesn't call
for it whereas it does feel like nihal has been
particularly measured today he um has had moments
where he's gone for it i think he's a little bit
still showing too much restraint but he has
been more balanced i would say than hike has
yes yeah he is he has shown and also his speed
right at the end but he's got two or three
seconds left has been phenomenal which is a very
good sign for him going into the bullet section
um okay well he's he's now got this uh this
obviously clear advantage in the position by
taking on h7 at the same time queen b2 only moved
but isn't black's position really creaking here
yeah holding on by a thread and well what move
to play for white roxy too it's pretty simple
rook c2 looks like the oh wait
my game needed your king oh yeah
rook c2 is it's i didn't see that either i didn't
hurt me brook c2 and it and it's mate but okay
hide me no don't look at me i blundered checkmate
whoa queen h4 check throwing in a check before
taking this bishop she's just showing off
um oh man it's quite hard comet i mean it's
hard playing in this probably harder playing but
commentating and keeping up the ideas the amount
of bla mates i've blundered and queen queen things
is in the thousands during commentary by now yeah
you know forgetting that the bishop on d6 covers
the only escape square we all make that mistake
it's happened to the best of us but definitely
definitely okay so the rook and d8 is hanging
so and then he wanted to go to g8 but he never
had the opportunity to is it now knight c6 is no
okay you've got bishop f8 always something you say
okay so bishop f8 blocks and is black trying
to play e5 and win this b3 pawn and say hey my
queenside pawns are too strong for you it's really
weird it feels to me that black's play shouldn't
work but he's kind of making it work somehow i
mean but you know putting your king on back on its
start square your bishop next to it is he going to
try to put the rook in the corner and the queen i
mean it shouldn't work but he's keeping his at
least he's keeping that defensive position but
now this is clever swinging the queen over
to the other side of the board it looks like
a good idea yeah boat look at the time though
if if hake well if he loses this one hike sorry
uh it's i think it's going to be too much again
as king's on e7 that's not good he's stopping
knight of five so you can play e5 if he wants to
came back to eight so maybe i mean i feel like
white should have something here it just looks
like a position where white should be better
so get your knight around to the light square
and i think also in this situation white should
be the one playing on even if he's not better
black is in more dangerous and some check just
the king safety and queen g8 but the queen of b3
protects very importantly the f7 square so maybe
rook c1 will i know the queen's the rooks will
come off then so we're going to now looks good
okay look at the speed though they're going
this is where this is where in the past knee
how is sean you know neha's really shown that
when he gets that you know and is he going
to do it again he's causing problems he's
causing a lot of problems rook d1 this is
the the piece is starting to coordinate yeah queen
d5 as possible it was rookie five or queen d3 rook
d check that's his new idea um i don't think we d3
as well and like yeah there's lots of ideas here
so rookie check this king has she said 97 check g7
still so he gave himself some space and maybe it's
black with that palm before who can turn this
one around very clever what black did they're
getting the kings of g7 i mean that king was the
one problem that black had but now he's got queen
d1 is he gonna be able to get it in get some play
queen five seconds left [ __ ] you have six and
there's one can't stop it he's got mate oh my god
gosh wouldn't he's gonna he's gonna win it what an
important win that was whoa well well done
to hike right yeah let's look at that really
quickly because that was just something crazy
there where it felt like nissan was pushing
did you know how old i was in that picture by
the way uh we just got our producer telling us
unbelievable you know that that picture of
me which you just saw apparently i was 24.
i thought i was 17. i was 24 years old yes they
were no you weren't i think i might have been
i was quite baby-faced and and and fairly fairly
fairly uh healthy chap and then and then and then
you know didn't even repair shops pear-shaped wow
i guess uh with quindy one that only was queen of
b3 in that position to stop it and white is up
a pawn for the time being but he goes forward
thinking he gets this check in but it's only one
check after queen d1 he takes on e5 and loses the
game and i guess knight h2 is the only move to
survive but who's playing that with no time in
your clocks let's get to the uh current game
i still can't believe that you were 24 there
i mean i was obviously a long yeah i mean getting
served in the bars was always a bit of a problem
that's why that's why i had to grow the
bears you know just so i could get a beer
um well that was an important win i mean how we
got this is the last game of this segment and if
hike can get this one get this one under his belt
then there's only two games in it in the bullet
which is which is really doable right yeah for
sure and these type of positions i like from
white's point of view hike has a spatial edge with
the white pieces you just play c4 claim some more
space and say hey man what are you going to do
with your knights they're just not getting active
for black and d4 you can put your knight into d5
please take me i'll take with my e-pawn i really
would not like to have nihal's position yeah
this is getting very close this match and very
important last win as you say white's position to
be preferred here knight g6 there's a lot of ways
you can play this you can even start throwing
a rook just simply to a7 maybe you can go rook
d1 i mean he's gone rook d1 centralizing i don't
like the choice of rook though because the e4 pawn
is already defended so i would have put the e rook
on d1 and left my rook over on a1 in the open file
okay white still must be better though white has
this extra space he can push with and that's a
nice move i like that g3 just stopping black's
knight diving into the position very i just think
this is a really important game robert don't you
because just from a psychological point of view
if hike wins this he's got two games in the bullet
section that is very doable he's still doable even
if he doesn't win but you know he's going to throw
knee how off kilter a little bit when the break
occurs as well and i think the break actually
would come at a perfect time for both players
if nihal does lose this game it will just give
him time to take a breath to relax say you know
i've lost two games in a row that's not good but
i still have two game leader for hike although he
would have what you would think of as the momentum
the play itself has been shaky at times so he can
get his you know mind ready for the bullet portion
when really that's just anybody's chance because
the bullet is just hectic it's chaos and uh
he has just as good of a chance well i won't
say that nihal is the better bullet player
but hike is an amazing bullet player himself
yeah so i think knee how's now going to try to
go for well exchanges if he can because white's
pieces are better but it's a space advantage which
is a problem for black because the other thing
is if if white ever plays b6 or c6 and then then
white can just try to win that remaining pawn and
his pawns are so near queening in in in
game positions um is also his knights
are better right robert because the knight
on e3 has more potential that knight on g6
is a really bad piece um yes it's it's not good
nowhere to go with that knight and it has to
stay here to help protect the e5 pawn so it's
a defensive knight and it can't jump anywhere
look at this knight d5 taking advantage of the
extra space and if i can move your knight away
from f6 then i can play h5 and win your e5
pawn very directly yes it's just i mean if
you take on d5 i can even take with the e pawn
and now i have three of these pawns in the fifth
rank pushing four i just wonder if you should
try that in queen f5 or something i mean like
maybe he has to take the knight here i don't
see many other options sense from your voice
you're like i don't really want to do that but i i
don't want to do it because like you say he takes
if you're not falling into some tactics it's
just going to be very strong i mean queen f5
is the only thing to cause problems okay he's
gone rook takes rook takes controls the position
i guess better yeah and h5 still a threat knight
getting kicked the e5 pawn is under attack already
and he'll take with the queen on d5 and keep
that queen stuck on c8 so maybe this was the
better choice i would have been too tempted to
take with the pawn though look at the time look
at the time two minutes versus 20 seconds this is
this has to be one if white does not win this one
it's i mean it there's some kind of knight of
four at some point because you can't take it but i
guess it doesn't quite f6 that's a good move very
necessary yeah now knight h4 has to be played come
here that looks pretty dangerous nine of five
coming so he drops the queen back and it's funny
you don't want to trade queens as white but there
are times where trading the queen's actually still
works out for you yeah i guess keep the queen as
active as you can maybe just queen b8 here looks
like queen d1 checking take on h5 oh so he has to
watch out for that quindy one check is going to be
an option and actually every queen d won oh and he
doesn't have any more if the king went to g quinty
one for sure like when you won and then you choose
this knight at four check haha knight f4 after
king g2 because you've queen there's black turning
this around yes okay knight f5 knight f4 right
yep this is knee house he's done it he's got the
knight in and he can actually take on h5 with the
queen because the knight is immune from capture
on f4 but he'll probably make the draw but queen
h5 says you can't take on my knight i mean the the
clock i mean the thing that i found with this is
it's in that game that was okay oh the
timer's up there i don't know if this
game's gonna count but i i i don't know
what the ruling is okay it's aborted but
the the this has happened a couple times but in
that position hike was doing very well on the
position uh he was clearly like had a nice
advantage and he had a two-minute advantage
but then knee how this has been the thing niihau
when he's had seconds left has played amazing
so i'm i the way it's going his bullet section i'd
be a little bit scared if i was on team hike at
the moment because he's already played bullet
chess and a lot of these games have done well
it's true i mean i'm looking at the clock
two minutes for hike 12 seconds for nihal
and in this position you want to flag your
opponent yes but when you have the advantage
and your opponent is nearing uh flagging territory
i mean move like queen b8 objectively is probably
better than queen c7 because you're pinning
the knight but you just need to be as just
difficult as possible and credit to nihal
for great defense here bringing the knight
out bringing the queen in and he did everything
right you couldn't ask for more he probably if
he had more time could you go queen takes age
five and play for a win or queen h3 and say you
know you can't take my knight without losing yours
but he did the smart thing with 6.9 seconds left
yeah oh well simon i mean before we go to break
let me ask you three game lead for nihal does
hike have a chance or did him not winning that
game really just relinquish all opportunity
he's definitely got a chance i mean don't don't
rule him out the way things are going obviously
niihau is strong favorite not just because
he's three games up but when he's got shorter
time he's playing brilliantly but if height
can just switch up a gear he's a brilliant
bullet player anyway and get a bit of a roll
going of course he can come back bullet chest
there's half an hour to go it's still open i
feel i'm with you there partner and well we will
see the final 30 minutes of this match in
the bullet when we return from this break and
there's more junior speeches championship action
brought to you by chess.com and chesskind.com
so
and we are getting set for the bullet portion of
this junior speed chess championship match and
just because this match should be over pretty soon
does not mean that the fun stops here at chess.com
after this there will be the speed chess
championship super swiss knockout today
is october 4th you see on the graphic here
12 p.m pacific time that's 3 p.m eastern
you know i don't know what it is in europe you
can see central european standard time there
but uh it's going to be a lot of fun but the top
16 players taking part in what is kind of an sec
mini format with a knockout bracket
yeah loads of good chess today
as always on chess.com um and this is this is the
exciting segment right robert i mean uh they're
they're ready to roll pretty much and uh can can
he do it can he come back knee how been playing so
well now but it's a one minute segment you can win
a load of game in the load of games quickly right
you certainly can and nihal is he's such
a great bullet player hike is as well but
throughout the match we've seen nihal play the
better chess between the two but bullet is just
anybody's game it's hectic there are so many
blunders that will be made but there also will
be some very good moves especially with that
one second increment yes so it's half an hour
one minute plus one and they are off so they've
gotta speed up both of them now looks like they're
gonna repeat the same opening with b6 right
surprise surprise simon yeah yeah i know and
you know this has actually i mean we say that
hake uh should have uh changed this but he's won
the last two games he's had in this even those
positions haven't really been that impressive
um so he needs to start strong i think if he gets
a win in the first game or two he can start the
role going and that's his chance it's three points
in it the games go quickly was there a tactic just
missed your bishop e4 what if bishop takes h7
queen d3 queen takes d7 we talked about this
earlier yeah yeah i mean that that that looks
like it wins the pawn right so he missed that
tactic but it is interesting because nihal played
knight e5 rather than knight g5 so he's the one
who switched the variation first and maybe
he has done a bit of prep here because
this position is looking a little bit shady isn't
it for for black i don't know a little bit no it
certainly is because bishop h4 bishop h4 oh gosh
that's a cruncher oh that's just killing that is
absolutely killing because you got you got oh
it's just that it's just a killer that's game
over i think game over it must be yeah rook d6
now you can put more pressure on this knight yeah
just the queen f3 yeah i think there's rook b6
here the only way to defend but this is not the
configuration of pieces you want from blacksmith
this is horrible right i mean you've nearly got
d7s but you don't need you don't need to go that
far of this position but i mean black's pieces
are all over the place here queen g47 you're
right yeah you have got rook d7 coming i mean
also just knight g3 to f5 is is a simple way to do
but put the rook on these win the piece game over
boom bad start there for hike bad bad start
do you see new house rating by the way 32 94.
is that even a real number i i don't know i mean
that's that's stupidly high what kind of rating
is that i mean come on man oh my gosh oh i didn't
realize it was that high i mean okay sorry sorry
hike you know you're a good player but that is
that's phenomenal right at this point stockfish
doesn't even have a chance against nihal in bullet
because in stockfish supposed to be like 3300
and komodo and all those engines oh so i mean
yeah hike is really up against it but he he um
you know he needs to do something he needs to
do something and he it does seem okay knee how
very solid here still yeah no weaknesses as such
yeah now this will come to d7 go after the d2 pawn
the dark squares in front of the king over here
knight d5 and force the bishop off the board if
you want to make that trade this doesn't look good
knight g4 can come yeah and you can start pushing
your a pawn as well as black just to cause a
little bit of probing you know i love pushing
those weak pawns it's a great move it really is
whoa oh he's just getting flashed now he's showing
us why he's like 3500 million waiting that is just
that's just showing off and it's a good move it's
a great move because the pawn indeed is pinned
and now you just uh undoubled your pawns and will
cause a weak pawn for white in the process simple
way to play simple and good he told it so quickly
yeah yeah so hike is really up against it um at
the moment being down on the score as well has
he got any hope of coming back and he's gonna
have to play the best chess of his life to to
have any any chance here he's fighting hard though
now he's got his rook coming around the back it's
it's potential chances you mean you
got queenie fives against that but i
i don't think you're going anywhere the king comes
to a6 but yeah at least that rook's got active
he's he's done something good there yeah he could
not just sit passively and defend him a6 which
that looks strange and rook h7 played with her
muscles aren't going to queen at f4 threatens both
queen fourth threatened both f7 and brook h8
checkmate okay so how do you defend against this
because rook rook check and queen b8 looks scary
can you just take that ball and not not be scared
bring the king can you do
that bring the king to b6
i like it i like it simon just take on d3 show
no fear show no fit if it works it works yeah so
yeah and he thinks it works and if it does work
it'll be another another point for nihal this
is this could be knee hell hour it really could
ah i just you're right rook h8 looks scary but
it's just a check king c7 queen b8 looks scary
as well but can be six there's no more checks
okay this is the best you can
do but you're not actually
threatening all that much here no i mean
black can always swap queens but he probably
shouldn't do that at the moment because c5
and yeah queen c5 check actually another
option here so rook h4 would be a blunder trying
to pin the rook because queen c5 check makes the
pin disappear yeah but queen f5 you can win
the rook but you lose your rook on d4 yeah
so queen c5 still looks like a good option
okay is he gonna okay now he's played c5
very tough position for white here queen f6 was
uh was good still could be coming though yeah
row takes b3 check oh queen d4 this could be
even better just the centralization with new
house pieces is incredible here i mean they're
just dominating the board and two seconds to
hike as well um it's another one it's another
point i don't see height coming back from this
now knee how's just playing too well at
the moment he's got to change this opening
don't play this opening hike what wheel out the
dutch why aren't you playing the dutch and simon
i'm surprised but neil isn't even the top bullet
player on the site i guess i should never be
surprised when he car is at the top of things
but hikaru for ruja grishouk didn't expect that
and then that's on draken fair chess
on youtube and then finally nihal
okay so top five in the world still pretty
pretty handy isn't it only only top five what
an underachiever no yeah he's got time he's still
got he's still got a couple of years on his side
he also sells a couple games on the side because
if he keeps winning he'll uh surpass andreikin in
fourth i mean again the opening robert here
has just gone knee how's way right i mean
he's he's won a pawn he's got hold of e5 black's
getting a bit desperate with some brook swinger i
think that rook f6 was a it seems more desperation
than anything else and i i mean you i think he's
it's two i think it's too late now but i can't
he can't play this opening anymore you just no
no and i mean this rook h6 is just there's knight
enough three bishops and you're not attacking
anything but this was already you know way past
the point of return because the opening has not
gone his way all match and we've said this time
and time again so for nihal getting comfortable
bullets his specialty in addition to being
an amazing bliss player nothing that i can do
no i mean it's a bit depressing when
you're in this situation and you're uh
you know you're facing you're facing someone so
strong you know you're a good player and hike
is an amazing player but nihal is just ruthless
absolutely ruthless and i'm looking at the match
like 22 minutes up so actually if hike can win
this game and start a winning streak then he has
a chance but he's not winning this game yeah
he needs to get him he needs a miracle really
um white's a very strong sea pawn up and black's
you know quite courageous throwing all those
pieces at white's king but everything is defended
everything is defended at whites everything too
many pieces for white over there and the c-pawn
can start running uh very quickly wait rook h5
okay that wasn't the best that gets a little
bit that makes it a little bit more complex
and down goes you know me five and you're only
15 seconds left wow okay i like that i really
like that knight g4 h3 that knight is pinned over
here he's found the only way out of it and uh but
now heights got a chance right because queen queen
is nice it's nice mcqueen but it's nice having the
c part isn't it i'd still rather be white don't
get me wrong but i mean it's better than it was
he's got a chance now oh maybe a ver the slimmest
of slim chances yeah not very not very big chance
like you can even play c6 here actually just
push that pawn through he does it and he has
he's played it with 5.6 seconds left more
than enough time with the increment for him to
push that's so quick he's so quick isn't he
queen e4 doesn't achieve anything because
f3 just blocking out the one fret towards
g2 and um he has to try bishop b7 but
there's some something nasty could occur
there with a king getting mated somehow right
bishop h4 in that position rook c5 oh
yeah okay so he's going for this way
you want to play rook b1 but do not blunder
your rook on that square i almost did
um so queen e4 f3 you saw this afternoon and
bishop f2 to block a check everything defended
where's the checkmate how do i
actually deliver the knockout
i hear you'll help me out it's getting close
yeah there's the checkmate ender game he does
it again he's just he's just crushing it isn't
he i mean he's literally just a monster at this
absolute monster he's free over 3 300 now insane
absolutely insane i can't can't count nearly that
high but he did pass on draken for number four
on in bullet on chess.com so what
a beast what an absolute monster
and by the way this opening also isn't going to
get white bishop hanging on reigns of course i
mean yeah oh i think he's just gone yeah this is
uh you can see you can see his body language now
i mean this this is the problem when someone's
playing so well against you even if you can
compete with them which i know height could on
a good day you know you start losing you know
the match is probably over it's it's just tilt
it's that poker term tilt isn't it which which
can occur and how long we got of this left 20
minutes can and and knee has won every game
right every day yes he has and you know we had the
dancing heads on uh stream here showing what the
odds were looking like and of course nihils
heavily favored and now at this point he's
pretty much locked the match up unless
he loses all the rest of the games
not gonna happen i mean even then you
can time out a little bit can't you
you could do a little bit of gameplay and just
wait and spend a bit of time and just like you
know there's too many points in it now too many
points um such a big gap and i mean look what he's
doing here with the white piece in this game he's
got a better position a better pawn structure and
oh gosh h4h5 kicking this knight making use of
this bishop on b2 one thing i've been really
impressed with robert is i i like i mentioned it
was only maybe two three i know years ago probably
three years ago where i played this tournament in
iceland which was um a very small tournament and
i was sharing this place with nihao and there
was only about five grand masters playing um
and niihau at that time he was strong don't
get me wrong we were sharing a place we look
we looked at a lot of chess together but he was
only like 2500 i say only he was only 2500 strong
which is great for his age but the amount he's
improved clearly in that quite small space of time
is phenomenal he was really talented he was really
really nice kid by the way as well very humble
very very inquisitive but the amount he's
improved in those three years and you can
just see it i can see the difference it's just
there glowing in his the way he's playing these
positions it's phenomenal and i don't know if
he has a coach if he does his coach is doing
a great job who is his coach you know he should
be here he must have a coach right i'm positive
he does and um i think it could be narayanan
i'm not positive on that i don't want to give
somebody else credit uh where it may not do but
i think it is and i mean what you're saying is
completely true simon and for some of these
players ratings don't tell the whole story
because they have some untapped rating gains and i
feel like that's where nihal is right now he's 26
20 or so and he's feels like he's playing
even better than that these days i i totally
agree i mean um he's he's he's improving and his
improvement a lot of people of i mean especially
when you're junior you haven't got to your
maximum you improve you improve but suddenly
you plateau you might even go down a little bit
but niihau seems to be still on that rise upwards
i mean just the fact i think even carlson magnus
carlsen approached nihal to be one of his seconds
um and i've i heard something like that i don't
know if that's true i could be making it up but i
think just the fact that carlson has this respect
for him shows and you know this is carlson he
knows how chess has played obviously and just that
fact just shows how good knee how is and how much
he's improving but he's he's he puts the work in
at the end of the day even if you're very talented
it is about the work he's going to win another
one here he's not sure much so easily it's the
work it's the coaching it's everything and he's he
seems to have the magic formula at the moment it's
it's amazing i did not know that actually though
that's a really interesting tip there i think i
might be right robert i i could have just made
that up of course but i think i heard something
like that yeah i think it's very plausible
because i've heard from some juniors about um
elite players asking them to work at seconds
i you know if i could say i would specifically
say who but i have you know confirmation of that
and so it's not that surprising to hear because
they may be young they may not have the experience
of the other top players but they have ideas they
have hunger and they're always searching for plans
and you hear somebody like daniel dubov who's not
as young as the participants in the junior
speeches championship but he is renowned for
his creativity any opening it may be the driest
of dry openings he still is coming up with the
unique idea here and there and that's why people
seek his advice in particular magnus carlson yeah
that's totally true and i i wonder how long it's
going to be until nihal is facing off against
magnus in in a serious sense of the of the words
i mean even here his position looked kind of worse
and he's just turned it around again i mean
he he was a bit worse i think me how obviously
hike is very he's going to be very depressed
now probably wants the match to be over but
he's just relentless absolutely relentless he's
won every game in the segment every single game
unbelievable wow and there's no wonder now why
nihal was the uh primitive favorite to win the
junior speeches championship not only is he an
amazing blitz player but he is an otherworldly
talent in bullets so no matter who he will face
in the finals whether it's jeffrey zhang or alexi
saranac they have their work clearly cut out
for them and if i am jeffrey if i'm alexi
what i'm doing is playing a lot of bullet in the
near future to get myself ready yeah yeah i mean
that's that's the thing you know you're going
to be up against it um in the bullet section
against nihal uh there's no doubt about that and
the other segments as well not just the bullet
um will he i mean bick is asking our producer
who's the best the best pick in the world there's
not many bics around so that's why he's the best
but yeah he's asking will this be adoption will it
will he actually i mean i don't really want to see
adoption that's a bit crawled at this stage but
is he going to win every game in this section uh
quincy five converge h6 so the answer is yes that
he is winning this game as well he's not gonna
win every game he's halfway through he's won every
game what odds would you say on him uh totally
adopting um well it's just crazy because hike
marty rosen might blank me if we played bullet
in this time control right he's 3040 himself
that is no slouch that is a superstar bullet
player in his own right and nihal's just
making it look easy and of course part of
it is the match history like you're playing
you know you're looking at the match score if
you started with a blank slate it could be a
bit different but i mean nihal is just i think
he's yeah i think he's gonna win every game
there's a good chance how can you stop him i mean
uh it's it's horrible you know just to stop him on
this run and again this is a better position and
also hike realizes he doesn't really want to be
playing now you know he uh he's he's had enough
okay well there's a glimmer here for hike hikers
won a pawn maybe no adoption anymore he's done a
little tactic he's grabbed the pawn this this is a
pawn up for hike he's just got to convert it he's
not the rod he has to watch out for f4 f5 that's
like the one idea that i'm looking at and what
just happened here he gave back a pawn but there's
too many tactics honestly my my head can't handle
wait wait no i'm totally the same i'm too slow
these guys are too quick i can't even get involved
with the chest at the moment it's too much for me
well that's still an extra pawn fry so he gave
up his queenside pawn for that central pawn and
here's the knight of g4 bishop e5 is a threat so
watch out for that he brings his knight back to
f5 for that reason very good square for the night
uh defending defending those things though okay i
don't think he's gonna lose this game well i mean
he's so far hike's played brilliantly in this game
yes oh nice move rook takes d4 has returned wins
the bishop on c4 two pieces under attack that's
a win for ike yeah now you can see you can see
nihal shaking his head there so even when he
loses one game this is kind of another side of
a champion they do want to win every game you
know is he gonna maybe he's gonna time out here
just to be safe is this like a bit of gameplay
okay he's trying some some bizarre tactic here uh
yeah i was looking at the match clock 12 minutes
just over there's no reason for oh look at this
cheeky tactic this is this is just this is just
like you know oh gosh that was too much knight
g3 check no because they're nice protecting
d1 i was looking at for a cool sacrifice f3 oh
everything's losing and know g3 check after that
but again you might as well draw the game out
just in case every every 30 seconds you save you
get nearer to victory very true and we'll see some
trades here an extra piece for black but using the
time just running the match clock no reason not
to why not clever gameplay you know it's it is
a sport i mean some people say oh he shouldn't do
this but he's going to win anyway and he's just uh
he's just doing it in the in the most professional
way i suppose the right word i'd like to see
knight in bishop versus king i don't think there's
much much of a chance of that but you know i would
like to see that that would be something yeah it's
not going to happen there's too many pawns there
how many times oh you can win one you can win
oh you won one of them all so if you can win
the other one come on you just got to take the
other pawn it's knight in bishop versus king how
many times have you had that end game in your
career never i've never had it i don't not not
not in a real game i've never had never had it
in a feed a raider game i think i can't i can't
remember having it so he's probably good because i
probably wouldn't win it you know how in american
tournaments there sometimes there's no increment
so i i played in some tournament without increment
and i was really in huge time trouble but i
had night in bishop it was a rapid tournament
and i'm down to the wire playing with an analog
clock you know with the little flag going up
and i did win the game within the allotment
because um my coach he drilled it into me like he
was like this is how you do it the m the w however
you want to look at it this is the pattern and i
did it super quickly and people were like well
how did you do that i was like you know practice
wiping the dirt off the shoulders brushing it off
but it looks good when you do it right oh yeah
yeah i mean again chess people think these guys
are magicians and they are but people who remember
the amount of hours both myself and robert and
the players here have put in behind the scenes and
you can't you can't get good at chess until you
unless you really practice i mean it you know it's
like anything in life you gotta you've got to put
the hours in if you want to if you want to achieve
certainly um and there are certain
theoretical end games that you just
need to know because you you really don't know
when it will come up for example simon you said
you've never had it in the feeder ready game but
if you did come up you would fully know how to
uh get the checkmate which is important and yeah
you know there's so many different end games out
there and it is important to study your theory
and this game is not an endgame just yet and look
at this h5 move and this is something we've talked
about many times is that you know if your opponent
is working on the queen side there are times you
just push your pawns over there on the king side
and h4 is a bit of annoying
threat here um at the moment
so he dropped the bishop back to e2 and
well simon something else i'm noticing
look at nihal's rating he's sad probably oh
that's why he was sad because he's gone below 23
300. i was going to say 2000 something
but i just remembered how high they were
i mean have you been over three thousand rocks
i know you're an awesome blitz player as well
i mean uh phenomenally quick i mean i i can
only dream of that 3000 number no no i mean that
number is reserved for really just the you
know elite of the elite yet upper echelon of
blitz town my high is something like 29.50 and i
was very proud to get that high yeah quickly went
down to i think i in like 20 50 territory now so
ah you know fine it's good but it's not these guys
i think on i the original icc i got over 3 000
but that was that was different different days
yeah i mean i don't know if neha was born when
you did that no it's like when i was over 3000
he probably wasn't around even what do we think
of this ending this is quite a peculiar one i
mean i i would say white i mean it's probably a
draw but if anything i'd probably take white here
uh i guess well now i'm definitely taking white
because uh these pawns are in some danger here
yeah clever play you wouldn't you actually went
up on my force b5 knight c7 so he goes bishop d7
giving up this pawn is a knight trap though you go
b3 can't you but then you might not be able to win
right so right if i take you on yeah it's not so
easy to win this so then i can go to c8 as well
he starts there yeah but where is it going next
yeah you gotta be careful of knight a7 bishop d7
but then b4 it's a weird position weird position
so plays a4 he's just trying to trap the knight
yeah actually you can't win this if knee how wins
this ending as well that would just be cruel yeah
stop it neha stop it how does this knight get
out though not easily wait i actually don't think
it does i like that oh but you can't go kennedy
seven because there's knight a7 so you actually
have a king d8 and then knight wait where's the
night going though it's still stuck he's trying
to triangulate oh to f7 so it's just drop oh my
gosh weird draw yeah you don't see a repetition
like that oh okay he's he's he had to do this yeah
because he's losing the match so badly and he's
had to try this this is actually maybe okay though
yeah he's got a lot of pawns his balls are big
three pawns the issue being that this b-pawn isn't
really an extra pawn because the a4 pawn stops two
of them well but the e pawns coming strong yeah
yeah too fast so he's going to get another win
nice one excuse me yeah king 70 67 i think it's
sure can you 75 he's 60 67 just push him yeah
so knee how's rating is dropping again
he's embarrassing himself with that rating
yeah i don't i don't think we can invite him to
any more tournaments right no he's
too low he's not over 300 anymore
and again he's probably going
to do the gameplay where he uh
takes his time and losing it it makes sense
um from sports point of view six minutes left
and i'm pretty sure hike can finish this one off
he definitely can yeah you know stalemate would
just be absolutely tragic at this point
it'd be quite funny but it'd be tragic
okay there we go okay but um so nice to see him
win a couple of games i think adoption would have
been very unfair to such a great player as as hike
and okay i like this he's changed his opening back
to back to this bit more exciting semi-slav
i'd like to see can you castle queen side no
he's playing this position online i want to see
that more fun castle in queensland this was the
first game wasn't it i was about to say we started
the match like this he's not going to deviate now
and here comes the knight to e4 and exactly what
we're talking about i think everybody remembers
what we were talking about in game one of course
everyone's got amazing memories you put the knight
on e4 and even then the bishop on b7 it got
has more space than it did with the pawn d5 but
that's the best it can do is going
to d5 and getting traded off yeah so
four minutes left and nihon a
bit of a drink of his drink there
and uh wondering how many more games we can get
in it's probably gonna be a couple more after
this many the endings are quite similar aren't
they this is even similar to the last game this
pawn structure they're getting it's like a
french defense kind of pawn structure where
where generally the black pawns are a little
bit weaker because the d5 but black has the
space advantage which certainly uh validates
it maybe white can go queen b5 now something
like this he has done and we just saw hike do this
from the white side where he tried to infiltrate
with his knight here it comes so similar idea
can the knight just go in and win these pawns
very similar well f5 saying so that's
key to tempo now knight c8 then knight a7
it's amazing how it's the same is that that's
like okay exactly the same right it's bizarre
yeah and that that was an important
sequence and nihal and i was up upon
versus being down the pawn in the
previous game but super similar
how do you wonder um don't ask
me questions like that this time
that's far too far too hard to work that one
out um i don't know i mean somehow just play
some moves yeah i agree with simon just play
some moves and then the win will be there but
maybe you bring your king to b5 or something like
this i don't know try and that's what he's trying
to do yeah the point we're getting at is that this
d4 pawn is the extra pawn but it can't really move
anywhere since the knight on f6 covers the
square if i could draw my arrows correctly
and if you ever play d5 my king just come
to c5 and i'm going to win that pawn at the
very least white can't push from there yeah
it's certainly not easy to convert this one
yeah this looks honestly just like it
might be a draw whoa well that's that's
that's an interesting way to draw basically
i mean you you assume the king of portland
is winning but there's no way the white
king can enter into the position here
certainly cannot not from anywhere um is he
going to take on e4 and just gamble a bit no okay
yeah this is a funny one you
don't see this very often
that draw the white king can't get in anywhere
it's quite funny there black offered a draw
okay now they got it by repetition so so two
minutes 24 left this could be the last game
most likely there's going to be two more
and uh we know who the winner is going to be
nihal i think we're going to try to get an
interview afterwards in i believe so it'd be
excellent to hear the thoughts of the players
um if it is both players or just knee how i'm
not not sure of but um i you know i want to i want
to hear what nihal's magic is of improving so much
what is his magic formula yeah he just was a
very different player out of the gates than
he was against smirnov smirnov really came out
swinging was up several points in the longest time
patrol but today nihal was the one who jumped
out to the early lead he lost that lead but
he still was much better at the start yeah and
this is much better for a hike by the way with
the bishop pair in particular is bishop
one b2 oh oh little little cheeky tactic
yeah he stole a pawn and should get the uh well
what's tactical sequence where rooks are being
captured from minor pieces i've just lost the
lost lost track here i think white's doing well
i'm going to stay there yeah white's obviously
doing well here the bishop on beaters robert
pointed out is a winner andrew and your material
up let's see have a pawn so the opposite color
bishops could give black better chances in the
end game but we're so far away from an end game
and with the weak king and unopposed bishop
and queen now on the diagonal yes certainly
white scheme to win it's probably going to be the
last game because there's only 45 seconds left now
um so we're assuming this is the last
game brilliant display today by nihal
absolutely absolutely play phenomenally well
i mean neither side has really blundered that
much no serious blunders and that just shows the
quality of you know i mean obviously heights gonna
be disappointed but his play wasn't terrible by
any means it was just knee how was phenomenal
today absolutely phenomenal yeah hike uh
played very well in spurts but ultimately
you know nihal just played better and the
bullet didn't help hike in the slightest
because neil is such a monster and here i think
he's just wasting the match clock the time is
officially over so this game is our last and rook
c7 just to defend against the mate smart move
yes watch out for 92 he moves king out the way
and he's going to take on g4 oh rook c2 oh my gosh
nothing for hike today is working when it
rains it pause right oh yeah and it's pouring
there's only one check on each it can come to
g6 safely okay that's a bit annoying but you
can move the queen away he does simply move
the queen yeah queen d6 oh i mean he just
really wants to he just wants he's showing off
with his magical moves now what a move to play
in splits i mean split second that's just a split
right there gosh because the queen takes would
have led to a checkmate in the back and he's gonna
repeat once and is he gonna is he just gonna take
the draw who knows oh my gosh you still can't
take rupee one check queen enforcement lovely
lovely way to finish the game so sharp he showed
positional plays today he showed tactical ability
and he showed fighting spirit i mean phenomenal
stuff well we are going to take a quick break
just to get the players on the call so we can
interview them uh this was a great match victory
from nihal sarin we'll hear his thoughts in
just a few don't go anywhere we'll be right back
so
and we are joined by a finalist in the
junior speeches championship nihal huge
congratulations on an epic win uh my first
question for you is what was different about the
longest time control because against
anton smirnov you were a bit sluggish
at the start but today you came out firing
with two victories in the first two games
uh yeah today i played a bit better i think
in general and yeah the five-minute portion
was a bit sloppy but then but then i managed to
play better yeah it seemed like your quality of
your chest i was very impressed with i mean
uh last time i i sort of saw you play was
maybe two three years ago and it seems like you've
got you've jumped a lot more you've progressed a
lot what's your secret in the last couple of years
hard work or uh or can you give us any secrets
yeah i think yeah thank you for that i think
i just think i just improved my openings
and okay i i got to play a lot
of strong players on chess.com
ah so chess.com yeah i play a lot here okay
that's good to hear i mean you know now your
bullet rating is i mean through the roof
and you start out with the bullet with like
five straight victories is that something that
you work on like do you put a lot of energy
into that or would you just say that you know
you're young and it comes pretty easily to you
yeah i think i i just like bullets the
most and yeah i just like bullet demos
i think that's my strongest point you were so
quick today there was many moments when you
just had for under five seconds left and you kept
finding very good moves very good resources and
i thought it was very impressive the way the way
you want because obviously hike is is a very good
player and um you kind of dominated especially
in the bullet section so again congratulations
there yeah thank you i don't think he was in
his best shape for sure yeah but i've played
much better for sure yeah well i have a question
we don't know who your next opponent will be
but it's either going to be jeffrey zhang or
alexis saranac do you have i'm sure you've played
both many times but is there somebody you'd rather
face or both are just you know worthy competitors
for you yeah both are definitely worthy yeah i
don't know it's a really tough choice i think
i don't really have a choice
because you just create strong
yeah i was gonna ask you what your experience is
like against those two i mean you know do you have
you played one of them more than the other oh yeah
i played quite a bit in sauna like i played in
i played him in cap dutch last year
and also leon masters this year and
yeah i lost two matches against
him so you want your revenge
yeah time for revenge yeah you have to
check his openings out and prepare properly
it must be nice to be in the
final though it feels good yeah
yeah well you know nihal i know it's uh getting
late by you i also have to go to another show
it doesn't uh my day does not stop right now
but we want to extend a huge congratulations
you were very impressive today you had so many
people rooting for you and i know that you're
making many people proud so your success as simon
noted is very uh you know awesome to see thank you
well done and good luck in the fight as
well anyhow thank you okay all right and
that was niall saarin after extremely impressive
victory over the very strong hike marti rossian
he moves on to the jscc final where he is a chance
to not only win the tournament but qualify for the
speed chess championship up next on the twitch.tv
chess channel is the speedchest super swiss
commentated by one grandmaster maurice ashley
and two you know a guy you may be familiar with
i'll be doing the commentary for that as well
so simon it's been an absolute pleasure do you
have any kind of final thoughts about the match
we just saw and maybe going forward in the jscc
well it's been it's been a very exciting match
i mean i think nihal just showed some amazing
ability there extremely impressive i mean before
the match i thought it'd be very close obviously
hike wasn't at his best standard today but that's
not taking any weight anything away from nihaon
he's going to be he's going to be really tough
to to defeat in the final um i would like to say
it's been a pleasure obviously working with you
robert and a bit of a pleasure working with bick
it's a massive pleasure uh thank you to everyone
else who's been obviously tuning in to the chat
everywhere and robert you've got a busy day today
so good good luck for the next event uh thank you
so much simon i mean it's been i guess a couple
years since we commentated together but i hope
it's much sooner than that the next time because
it really was a blast for me and of course our
audience makes it that much better the viewers
who you know are just bring such positivity and
such a love for the game of chess we appreciate
that so everybody stay safe uh enjoy more chess
just go over the you're getting rated so you're
gonna go over there right now but there's more
chess to be had with some superstar players for
the speed chest super swiss for now i'm gonna sign
off eat the quickest of quick lunches and then
commentate some more so see you soon everybody
you